princes and their wives
alistair
this wasn't expected
no the princeton princess of wales with
the duke and duchess of sussex coming
down the long walk to um
to cambridge gate interestingly and
perhaps after a short talk may be coming
out to meet
the public who are here a family
together
the prince of wales has only recently
issued his statement saying that he will
do whatever he can
to fully support the new king
coming down from windsor castle the
great george the fourth gate behind them
and framing their departure now from the
private area and coming into the public
part of the park where the long walk has
often had
many royal occasions not least more
recently when the duke and duchess of
sussex were married coming out to look
at the
enormous number of floral tributes laid
here for the queen who spent most of the
latter months of her life here at
windsor castle she was here throughout
covid
it was here that the duke of edinburgh
died
and it was a very special place for the
queen and prince philip probably their
principal home and for
their two grandsons to be here with
their wives
looking at those floral tributes
and
neither the
princess of wales as she is now nor uh
megan making the journey up to
to scotland
well they have families and
responsibilities and it matters only
that they're here now
in support of the king
and remembering
their grandmother
it is extraordinary the quantity of
contributions and things that have been
left by
members of the public to reflect upon
a queen whose reign was so long
one
okay
hello
two
three four
[Music]
oh
okay
thank
[Music]
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
bye
[Music]
in recent years and
i rather sense that for the late queen
knowing that her two grandsons are here
with their two wives
together supporting the king
and reflecting upon her and all the
kindnesses that have been shown in
reflection of the late queen's life
would be
very special to her she only really ever
cared that all the family
should be happy and she as was said by
the king
she always sold the very best in
everybody and she will have done that in
particular with all members of her
family
all right alistair thank you very much
uh rhiannon mills our royal
correspondent is also watching these
pictures with us and
rhiannon it's uh
interesting that
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
as long as you guys
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you
oh yeah
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
for
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
that's amazing
[Music]
you're playing with hawaii
move back outside
you want to hold them
[Music]
yes
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
coffee
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you say that yeah
[Music]
thank
okay
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this year
thank you
oh william okay
[Music]
hello
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
i'm a personal trainer
[Music]
hello
[Music]
um
[Music]
she
yes
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
keep breathing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
um
you're right
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
we would uh let you watch and listen to
these
remarkable pictures we're seeing outside
windsor castle and uh
in so many ways they really do
uh speak for themselves don't they
the prince and princess of wales the
duke and duchess of sussex out to meet
the huge crowds
that as you can see there what a picture
that is stretching
down the long walk at uh
windsor
these pictures also being watched by our
royal correspondent rhiannon mills and
uh
well rhiannon i mean with it
amid the great sadness
this will be delighting these crowds
i think at this most solemn of moments
this in a way will
bring a smile to many
it's been a moment that
so many people have wanted to see
a sense that
you have two brothers who in the past
were so so close
and have undoubtedly had a very
difficult couple of years
a lot of things have been said since the
sussexes decided they wanted to step
away from raw life
and yet
today we have them again
coming together
and
so naturally once again slipping into
that sense of
the royal duty the royal role
and
carrying out one of those walkabouts
that you have to remember it was
actually the queen and prince philip who
decided they were the first ones who
went out and made sure that they met as
many people as possible
and here we see
two men who
have no doubt had their difficulties
in the last couple of years and they've
both come together
really in a mark of respect and i think
to
to get out and meet the crowds and share
in this moment of
immense grief for so many
i understand that yesterday prince
william
um the new
prince of wales was mulling over whether
or not to to do a walk about of this
sort um with his wife catherine
and
it was earlier on today that he was the
one who approached
prince harry and megan and said look
would you like to to join us
when we go out there and meet the crowds
because of course they are they are in
essence now neighbours because they live
both live in
cottages very large houses but cottages
on the windsor estate so harry and megan
who purely by fate happened to be in
this country of course they moved away
to america when they decided to step
away from raw life when they were here
in the uk which they have been this week
carrying out engagements
they still have their base at frogmore
cottage and only this week
william and catherine's children of
course have started a new school very
close to windsor and they have decided
to move the family out to adelaide
cottage
and an awful lot was made about were the
two couples going to meet at all
when the sussexes were here in this
country and
in essence what we were hearing was
there was no communication and they
simply weren't going to talk and and the
last time that we saw the sussexes in
the uk so the platinum jubilee
there were suggestions that there was
this frostiness that was still
continuing when we saw them at st paul's
for that platinum jubilee
service the sussex is sitting in the
opposite aisle from the other senior
royals
but i think
what the queen always said
despite all of the difficulties that
were had
despite everything that was said
while she was alive
the sussex says she constantly repeated
were still much-loved members
of the royal family
and so
in a way you get the sense that they are
they're doing it for her
they are
or two men
who
over the years have
been united in grief
of course sharing the death of
of their mother
and now once again coming together
in this
incredible way
which is completely unexpected
to pay the ultimate respect to their
grandmother
[Music]
andreanan what is noticeable is
this is all generations here young and
old and
all out
just wanting to
see the royal family to pay tribute to
the royal family to pay their respects
to the to the royals
and we sort of get glimpses don't we of
those conversations that are being had i
think at one point prince william was
saying to some of the younger children
in the crowds have you heard of the
queen
um
and yeah there are smiles and and it
sort of resonates with this
this feeling that we've got when it
comes to what we've heard from the new
king when we've had his address to the
nation last night and also
the words that we heard from him at the
accession council where
he talked about how much it means to the
royal family when they are going through
this incredibly difficult time to know
that queen elizabeth ii was so widely
respected by so many
and in a briefing a couple of hours ago
we were told that
for the new king while yes of course
the state duties are very important at
the moment his main focus is going to be
leading the royal family our nation and
other commonwealth realms
in mourning really wanting to make sure
that he personally gets out to meet as
many members of the public as possible
to share in that grief here we also see
how in a way other members of the royal
family it seems are gaining some
some solace
from from being able to
to talk to the crowds
and you have to remember this is
something they weren't able to do
when we saw the death of the duke of
edinburgh due to covet
and yet now because those restrictions
have lifted because we're living in
different times the crowds can come out
in windsor and
prince william kate
harry and megan
have now spent
gosh almost 40 minutes
see shaking as many hands as possible
reaching out and grabbing those but
those bouquets of flowers we can see
megan there
handing over a bouquet and what's been
fascinating for me to watch knowing the
teams around them knowing
the prince and princess of wales's team
at one point i saw one one of their team
go over to megan and say
would you like me to take those flowers
from you i think there is this sense
look we're welcoming harry and megan
whatever's been said
some of it said very recently
whatever's been said
and said very publicly in the press this
is a time
not for
family squabbles this is a time
to listen to what the queen
would have said would have wanted
she
always described harry megan as much
loved members of the royal family and as
the king last night mentioned he talked
about how the queen had this unerring
ability always to see the best in people
and
today i think
we are seeing how
the prince and princess of wales are
following her example and saying look
in terms of
family problems family turmoil this is
not the week to draw attention to that
this is a week to come together to
remember her
and also
now support the new king
yes it's interesting we saw that
traditional side of the monarchy this
morning but here
right here outside windsor is the modern
monarchy in
action it is
and look the the
arrangements around
the death of queen elizabeth ii have
been
years in the planning and
and yes
the ceremonial
was always
the thing that we were briefed about the
certain events the ceremony that would
happen every day
today was was meant to be a day about
the accession council about that first
big ceremonial moment since the death of
the queen
in which we
saw the new king proclaimed as the new
monarch the pageantry around that the
celebration the fanfare
but also you have of course many people
still wanting to
pay their respects
and and mourn the queen
and there is no doubt that the way that
the royal
family in these pictures in this moment
have spent
gosh almost 40 minutes speaking to as
many people as possible
this is what matters to many people up
and down the country
this is the way that
they connect
and of course that tradition
was started by the queen
she was the one who always realized that
the royal family must stay relevant if
they're to survive
and
it's been difficult it has been
difficult for the family we live in much
less deferential times we live
in a time where the media have wanted to
know
about the relationship between
the cambridges and the sussex states
and i think with this moment
the prince of wales the new prince of
wales we see there
almost getting into that car for him
he made that decision that he was going
to ask
the duke and duchess of sussex to join
him today on this walk about
and
in essence show that they are united try
to put to bed the questions that were
going to remain this week about would
the sussexes be involved
and
with this one move
with this
remarkable walkabout
we can see them now
i'll just pause
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and there they go
getting into their cars
the two couples
who on the marriage of harry and megan
were
described as the fab four
who have had their difficulties
over the past couple of years
but today have been very much
united
when it comes to paying their respects
to their much beloved granny
yes rihanna we've uh stayed with these
pictures for obvious reasons it has
passed uh six o'clock uh just past six
o'clock you're watching
live pictures from outside windsor
castle
down the long walk there the crowds have
been gathering and they've just
been delighted as the two brothers
came out
prince and princess of wales the duke
and duchess of sussex as they
wend their way
uh back to
the castle and uh
and the crowds still um
in on the vehicles and the police
uh keeping them uh
off the long walk and uh these are
extraordinary scenes one has to say and
rhiannon
it was the new king king charles who
expressly said
in his uh
speech to the nation talked about his
love for
uh harry and megan
yes and for what was such a historic
address his first
as the new monarch
it was
it was an unexpected turn
but i i think it it chimed with
other elements of that message which
were
trying to draw a line under certain
questions at the start of of his reign
so as well as talking about yes camilla
must be queen consort and
confirming that yes he had given the
title of prince and princess of wales to
his son prince william the fact that he
turned around and
expressed his love for harry and megan
was
automatically including them
within the family despite their decision
to step away from raw life
and
this moment
was completely unexpected i had
anticipated
that
william and kate may carry out some kind
of
walk about this afternoon
but
to be joined by
by a couple after
a difficult couple of years
some pretty awful things have been said
but today it was about drawing a line
under that and
this was not about them
this was about
paying the ultimate
tribute
to
their grandmother their granny as prince
william
described her
in his statement that that he released
and an incredible walk about 40 minutes
they spent
quietly
pausing chatting to as many people as
possible
taking the flowers
and
the team around william and kate i think
just as conscious not just about
helping out
them but also making sure that harry and
megan were okay
and also i think of course the crowd
there very loyal fans no doubt
harry and megan of course
their reputation
has
in some senses they have fallen out of
favor with some
but i think this was
certainly william saying look they
should be they should be welcomed today
and you could see that that harry and
megan also received
a great reception um from those that
they were meeting over the other side of
the barriers and
i think as we look ahead at the next few
days we now already have more plans of
what's going to happen a greater sense
of what's what's going to happen in
terms of the planning um questions about
would the sussexes be involved would
harry for example be involved in in any
of the
processions when it came to
funerals or when it came to
services that are taking place
i think in a way this this answers that
question
they are they are welcome this is
yes an enormous moment for our country
but it is a family in mourning and um
today we have seen very clearly in these
pictures
how
this moment
the shock the sadness
has brought them together
yes and rhiannon we're just uh
beginning to see signs of
some sort of movement here at buckingham
palace as well but just
just tell us in more detail about the
events that they have laid out
for the coming days
so of course these events have been a
very long time in the planning but it
was up to the king to give the final uh
sign off
to the plans i think the main point that
many people waiting for was confirmation
of the date
of the state funeral we now understand
that is going to happen on monday the
19th of september it'll happen at 11 a.m
in westminster abbey and subsequently
the queen's coffin will then uh be taken
to windsor for a burial service
um in terms of what happens tomorrow
we know now that the queen's coffin is
going to leave balmoral
where she is currently
um her coffin is currently in the
ballroom which has allowed
members of staff to to pay their
respects tomorrow however she will be
that coffin will be moved by six game
keepers
and put into a hearse and then slowly
driven from balmoral to edinburgh and
due to arrive in edinburgh at around 3
30 this afternoon at hollywood house
where again the coffin will be placed
inside the palace of hollywood house and
will
that will allow members of staff there
to also pay
their respects
on monday the 12th uh we will see the
coffin then moved to saint giles
cathedral now that will be a procession
which will be joined by her family and
we can just
i'm just going yes we can this is the
state car
well this is the state car containing
uh king charles
iii and uh we presume his queen consort
emerging from buckingham palace so let's
just have a
listen to what is happening here
[Applause]
uh
right
look at that
[Applause]
uh
i i said i assumed the queen uh consort
was uh with him but it's assumptions are
dangerous because i don't think it was
uh no it wasn't it was
in there but uh where he's going i don't
know
alongside him was um clive alterton who
is his principal private secretary um
a man who no doubt
over the last few days has been
invaluable to him as an advisor he's
worked with the prince wales for a very
long time
and
he is utterly devoted to serving him
um and
he
will no doubt be helping to make sure
that the new king
is
trying to keep up with this
relentless schedule that he is now
facing over over the next few days as he
has automatically
picked up the baton when it comes to
carrying out those um constitutional
responsibilities it looks like they may
well be heading towards oh gosh no it
looks like they're stopping and
potentially getting out
we may well have another walk about
happening on the mail
hopefully that camera can can reposition
and well it does look good
yes he does and it looks like or it
feels
a bit like this has been choreographed
so
william and harry were out in windsor
and now it would appear that uh
prince charles is
out and about off the mall
so
well we hope to get these uh pictures
for for you i said prince charles i keep
it's got to get used to king charles the
third haven't we rhiannon
absolutely i've done it mark
prince charles as we knew him um but now
yes
it's difficult in a way to get used to
him being king charles but he has also
had to to adjust to all of this as
quickly as we have
i think what's um
what's happening though is he he really
wants to
[Music]
get out and meet as many people as
possible and actually that was made
clear in a briefing a couple of
hours ago that we know he's he's had a
busy afternoon when it comes to
to getting on with the
the matters of state when it comes to
meeting the prime minister again and
meeting the cabinet meeting opposition
leaders he's met up with the archbishop
of canterbury and tomorrow he'll meet
the secretary general of the
commonwealth
but for him
this is an important moment where he
knows he is expected to lead
just as his mother did
during what is a difficult time for this
country and
as he said
he he shares that sense of loss
beyond measure
with everyone in this country with
everyone around the world he wants to
get out and share in that grief um while
also
trying to lead the royal family um this
country and
all those commonwealth realms
in those in various different ways in
which we're mourning queen elizabeth ii
but what really stands out to me is
for years now the plans have been in
place
around what would happen in in the days
after queen elizabeth ii died
and
we're not entirely seeing them rip the
rule book up
of course today the the big event the
big ceremonial moment was the accession
council that moment that we saw king
charles iii formerly proclaimed as king
ancient ritual that we've not seen for
70 years
it was a historic moment
and yet
this
in essence is
a new
modern
adaptable monarchy
in action
but i don't necessarily think it's being
done in any kind of contrived way
certainly from
the the many hundreds of engagements
that i followed members of the royal
family on
this is what they do and actually this
is what they love doing most is
getting out there
meeting people
connecting with people trying to get a
sense of how are people feeling and and
i just think that is absolutely vital
for king charles
for his relatives
for the palace advisors to to really try
and soak up the atmosphere to really try
and get the temperature
how are people feeling at the moment
because it is a lot to come to terms
with this has all happened so quickly
and i don't think we're the only ones in
shock well i i know we're not the only
ones in shock this has come as a great
shock to members of the royal family and
for them now they can get out there
connect meet people and try to share in
that sense of grief um amongst all of
the pageantry the ceremony that we are
also seeing unfold
yes well it's been a remarkable hour or
so we've had some extraordinary pictures
of the prince and princess of wales and
the duke and duchess of sussex in
windsor now we have
king charles iii who's driven out of
buckingham palace a few
well a couple of hundred yards i'm
guessing from uh
the palace he's got out and he's gone
into the crowds we assume frustratingly
no pictures melania vessel novich our
correspondent is
there somewhere among the crowds um what
did you see molina
well we saw king charles the new monarch
go in his car throughout the gates of
buckingham palace right behind me drive
very slowly greet all of the well wishes
you can see on the other side of this
street and then just slowly slowly make
his way towards mal and here to see him
were also nikki and caitlin who came all
the way from ken today and saw the new
king how was that moment
monumental it's one of those moments in
history that you just have to kind of
see and experience how about for
yourself caitlyn it's definitely going
to be one for the kids so i'm definitely
going to be able to tell my children
that i came up here i'm just going to
lay the flowers i've got to see the new
king
and it's just it is it's
can't put it into words and you really
got to see him it was only a few meters
away he was so close to here how did
that feel it's it's
it's amazing to kind of like to actually
be to be able to be that close and to
actually experience it and see in real
life rather than watching it on the
telly and why was it important for you
to come here today and witness this day
i think because it's it's obviously like
the monarchy is such a big deal and
everyone comes around the world to see
like the queen see all the buckingham
palace i think it's just it's just
something you have to do it's like
they're kind of part of yours yeah it's
part of your inner family aren't they in
a way that you're just they're they're
part of us and we feel that we want to
be there and it's like when the queen
like when she passed it was it's like
you lose like a part of you because you
don't know her but it's like it is sad
it's like she's like a nan and a grand
to everybody and you want to come and
pay your respects
for for her in that moment and now
you've seen uh the new king in close
quarters you've been here a few hours
waiting for this moment how does it feel
amazing yeah
it's a lot to take in but i think it's
gonna be one one for the
to remember thank you very much thank
you so lots of quite reflection of
course about the queen's passing but
also a sense of new beginnings with a
new monarch and a new era of king
charles iii
melina thank you very much we're going
to stick on these pictures in the hope
of seeing king charles uh
in the very near future but he is um it
seems as if he is out meeting people
just alongside the male there
let's bring in the right reverend graham
usher bishop of norwich
sandringham is in his diocese thank you
very much for being with us just first
of all i don't know whether you've been
seeing the pictures of extraordinary
images of the prince and princess of
wales the duke and duchess of sussex
out among people
in
windsor
it just seems there is this
real affection amid the sadness for the
royals today
i think that's absolutely right and
yesterday i was at the gates uh to
sandringham house where people were in
somber mood and and quiet and reflective
but great outpouring of love uh for uh
the memory of of the late queen but but
also for the the new king and for all
the members of the royal family who very
much held in people's prayers at this
time and lovely to see uh the royal
princes and their wives together uh out
uh in in windsor
yes so the scenes we're seeing windsor
of course uh
i was in balmoral
on thursday evening people coming out
there now you're
well sandringham is in your diocese what
has been the reaction of the people
there
well i was i was there yesterday and
people there were coming to lay flowers
um
interesting talking to a number of
people how their own sense of previous
losses and bereavement in their life was
was welling up within them and and many
were were very tearful not only for uh
the death of of the late queen but but
also remembering those who they have
loved and seen uh no longer
the estate workers were there you know
doing their duty uh doing their their
role of course the queen was a neighbor
to so many people on the sandringham
estate she was seen out and about and
she would go and visit her new polls
there
she went to the wi she was very much a
parishioner at st mary magdalene church
every sunday when she was in residence
there's there's a lovely story told when
she went into
one of the the local shops i think with
a head scarf on them and
somebody said to her um you look very
much like the queen and
she responded how very reassuring
yes well there's all these stories and
uh we're just going to continue watching
these pictures we witnessed
a few moments ago and
let's just talk about what we saw this
morning the
the inside workings if you like of the
monarchy and the constitution the
traditional side of the
the monarchy and of course religion and
faith
a fundamental part of it
that's right and seeing that commitment
to the church of scotland and and the
and the princes in the the little
symbols uh you know how the king held uh
a blue colored uh cover on the bible he
was holding to make his oath
the colors of of the scottish and
andrews flag was a a lovely small touch
in all of that and it was you know those
deep sense of tradition and history of
that being passed on something that none
of us had had witnessed uh before
uh but also a sense of affection and
love for the new king and queen and and
their family uh a somber uh time but
also at a time that uh of looking
forward and looking forward with with
hope and and imagination for for what
his reign will bring
yes and just looking back if we may i
mean at sandringham you i gather visited
the queen often
well there's been a tradition that the
bishops of norwich have
spent the weekend after christmas each
year sandringham uh i was able to do
that in my first year here it was then
uh covid uh did you know cancelled uh
subsequently but i i would go over to
sandringham to wood farm on the estate
where mcqueen was then have lunch with
her or or simply go to
to spend some time with her
and that was a
huge honor in my life
but also a great joy because we would
have a good a good leather about all
sorts of things and uh she gave me very
wise advice on various things but was
always interested in the life of the
church of england and particularly in
the diocese of norwich and i was amazed
how knowledgeable she was uh about all
sorts of aspects of the church's life
and indeed it was a huge privilege to
pray with her there uh just in the days
leading up uh to the 70th anniversary of
her exceeding to the to the throne
okay reverend uh thank you very much
right reverend graham usher uh bishop of
norwich joining me there thank you and
i'm joined now uh here by sir david
manning former british ambassador to the
u.s and also
a former adviser to the new prince of
wales and i don't know if we can see
some of the pictures again
of uh the new prince of wales in the
last few minutes but they have been uh
here we go quite extraordinary scenes
yes
no it's wonderful to see him out and
about with the princess of wales because
they're going to be a tremendous team
and
it's very nice to see them in their new
roles
together with the duke and duchess of
sussex too
and he made earlier this afternoon a
very personal statement about granny and
how important
she was in his life yes
and that was always very clear to me
she took an enormous interest in what he
was doing in the family
and always wanted to know how his
overseas trips had gone for instance
and he had regular contact with her
and i think
always takes
her service as his model
and i think that they will
very much try to cast themselves the new
prince and princess of wales in that
model
um and follow it
and as he says in his message
and do everything he can to support his
father as king absolutely i was going to
say i'm absolutely dedicated to
the service of uh the new king yes yes
and what about uh the new king what sort
of monarch do you think he will be i
think he'll be very successful um he
goes without saying that he has watched
from for a long time
and has had plenty of time to see what
the role requires and i thought his
first statement
to the nation was extremely moving and
very powerful and he seems to me to move
very quickly into the role of the the
sort of the reassuring unifying figure
that the country needs it's interesting
i mean it's very
rarely that you begin to fulfill your
destiny at the age of
73 absolutely it's an unusual situation
yes well as as i'm 72 i realize that i
realize that's true maybe you've yet to
fulfill yours well who knows who knows
and i mean how do you think he will
ray um
model himself on on his mother she's
been after all an extraordinary figure
for for unifying the country she's been
somebody who has been always there for
us
um above politics uh a figure of great
reassurance and i think that that is
certainly in troubled times a role that
people will hope he can play and i
believe he can
as you say he has had this
length of time to watch and to
listen to his mother so he is
he is prepared for it
he's had a
i mean an interesting time as prince of
wales with all the issues that he's
become involved with but he's very clear
isn't he that uh
no no meddling
use it very much i think to promote
causes that he passionately believes in
we are getting a king we have a king who
really knows his mind and believes
passionately in things like
environmentalism uh the prince's trust
which has helped enormous numbers of
young people often from very deprived
backgrounds
and he indeed the new prince of wales
have also got an enormous network of
contacts it's not just in britain
but they come into their new roles
knowing an enormous number of people
right way around the world that is a
huge asset for a country that aspires to
have a global a global role
and on the
idea of
global role and
you're a former
ambassador to the united states i think
joe biden has already made it clear that
he is he is coming a great affection in
america of course for the royal family
there's huge affection um in 2007 i was
a ambassador in washington and
the the queen and prince philip came on
what turned out to be their last
visit their last state visit to the
united states and it was exactly 50
years after the first visit and they
arrived at williamsburg in virginia
and
what was very striking
was that in the hotel where they were
staying they had put up the photographs
of the queen in 1957 and what an
astonishingly beautiful young woman she
was i'm not sure how much of this has
come out in in the coverage recently but
she was she looked absolutely wonderful
and she won hearts then
and certainly when she came for that
visit in 2007
um there was an enormous amount of
affection and admiration for her and she
was for americans just as for brits a
sort of an extraordinary
walking history book if you like her
first
american president have been eisenhower
her first prime minister been churchill
and i remember that she and
prince philip went around what was then
the new world war ii memorial with
president bush the second's mother and
father i.e the first president bush and
to see them paying tribute to what the
americans at that stage were calling the
greatest generation
it connected the british royal family
very immediately with uh
with american
preoccupations and with their own
american president
and just finally sir david uh what is
your abiding you've met her clearly a
few times what would your abiding memory
be of
the queen well lots of people have
talked about the twinkle and there was
always this extremely um
it was extremely nice to talk to her she
she was very shrewd she was humorous she
had a very nice sense of humor
she was very sharp
and you better know what you're talking
about and i can remember thinking that
on an awful lot of these issues if
you're not very careful she knows more
about them than you do and she's
certainly much more experienced than you
are and when she came to the united
states and we were briefing her her
questions were extraordinarily
sharp and to the point so she was
somebody who i think
as everybody has said worked extremely
hard but my goodness me she really knew
her brief
yes
sir david thank you very much for coming
in it's been very interesting thank you
for joining us
this afternoon joining me now is sir
stephen lamport
vice lord lieutenant of surrey who was
the private secretary
and treasurer to king charles for
many years uh then prince charles of
course so uh
so stephen charles is
king it was fascinating to see wasn't it
the proclamations this morning that
glimpse inside the workings of the the
monarchy and the constitution
yes it was and i i know
i mean that it's something which uh
as i think the prince has made little
kingdoms news is made clear over over
the last few days it was a moment he was
he was dreading but it was a very solemn
and a very i thought a very sort of
emotionally powerful um marching of what
is clearly an important change in
in the life of our country and it was
done with great trump the great ceremony
and i thought with the great time
with great emotional commitment too i
mean what the brief the brief words of
the king used when he made his a brief
address to um
to the council i think were very
powerful as as his words were last night
when he pledged himself to want to serve
this country in the way that his
his mother has done um knowing very much
that his life is not going to be as long
as hers has been as sovereign
but clearly committed to giving to the
country the the leadership and the
commitment and above all the service and
the duty which his mother gave over such
a long time and i think that's an
important aspect of of this new brain
that um it is going to be very much a
continuation of many of those things
which the queen stood for which was a
hallmark
of what constitutes its intermediary
kind of
what you might call a civilized society
in the monarchy's role
in achieving i mean it's very great i
mean it stands for service and duty and
continuity and respect it stands for a
love of the country it stands for the
ability to in a sense to see above the
political day-to-day fray and to take a
very long-term interest in what the
country's future good is to be and i
think all that has come across if i may
say very powerfully of the last 24 hours
yes you certainly had time to watch and
to listen uh how it's done
um it's a it's a tough act to follow
isn't it
it is but you know there's never been a
better prepared prince of wales i mean
he's spent five decades and more in a
sense of understanding what the world is
practicing um many aspects of what the
world constitutes um i mean we've never
had a better prepared principles and he
has i mean quality of understanding
and knowledge of the country of the
people both in this country and indeed
around the world which i think is
incomparable and i know
that he'll put that to extraordinary
good and effective use for the for the
good of this country
during his reign that's very much i
think the kind of man you know which we
have now our king
it's very interesting isn't it because
when the queen exceeded the throne of
course people knew
well very little about her really she
was so young people know quite a lot
more about charles and i guess that has
advantages and disadvantages
i think i think that's almost certainly
true but i think one of the things that
people perhaps don't often understand
about about what is the prince of
wellness he was and the kings he now is
is that apart from his extraordinary
commitment to this country which he
which he dearly loves as we all
understand
and can see he has an extraordinary
ability to to relate to people his i
mean his style of people is is second to
none and it's not easy when you are the
prince of wales or the monarch in a
sense to deal with people in a way which
they which puts them into a position
which they find um
which they find helpful and and
reasonable and if i can give you one
example if i may of
of how effective he is with people a
number of years ago um it was just
before christmas time you were going up
to scotland to visit flood victims of
people who had suffered from flooding
around paisley in southwest of glasgow
and um we arrived at a particular
engagement where there was a there was a
lot of civic dignities outside the mayor
and the senior local councillors and so
on to welcome them into
an operation they were doing to provide
supplies and white foods to the people
who had been flooded out of their houses
and as the car drew up um and the and
and the man was there ready to meet the
principal doesn't greet him on the other
side of the road was it was a group of
about half a dozen pretty fierce looking
young chaps very i mean looking very
cross and very and very almost hostile
and we got out of the car and will saw
them
and what he did was was not actually to
shake the hand of the mayor first of all
but to go across the road and talk to
these to these chaps and after five
minutes it was extraordinary that that
atmosphere was completely different and
when the prince of wales i mean um left
them they were laughing they were
chatting to him and when he left the
engagement there they were cheering his
departure that says something about his
ability to relate to ordinary people in
the way that princess
and helps to organize people it's
something which i think is an important
aspect of what he is and what he will be
as king and what his ability will be to
in sensitive to communicate with people
in a way which is i think very effective
and and very heartwarming too
yeah very interesting so stephen lamport
really appreciate your time thank you so
much
well we saw some pictures a short while
ago of
the new king charles meeting politicians
well the house of commons is sitting
this evening for a second day of
tributes from
mps to the queen senior members have
also been swearing the oath of
allegiance to king charles iii
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare an affair that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law
i do swear that i will be faithful and
be of true allegiance to his majesty
kenny charles his hairs and successors
according to lord it's a helping god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord
so help me god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and fair true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help with
god
so that's what's been going on in the
commons we've seen some
well remarkable pictures in windsor in
the last hour or so uh sky is sam
washington is there sam uh well that was
quite something you witnessed
yes wasn't it just as you were saying i
am here
in windsor where the two brothers
william and harry they spent nearly an
hour greeting the crowd there the death
of the queen and the proclamation of
king charles are both being marked
across the country now wrexham in north
wales was awarded city status as part of
the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations and it was due to celebrate
that award this weekend well instead its
residents are now coming to terms with
the death of the monarch and the
beginning of a new era of royal rule
sky's katarina vertosi reports from the
new city
[Music]
today in wrexham as church bells rang
out to mark king charles's accession
inside a model of the late queen's crown
came down
there was meant to be a party here today
to mark wrexham getting city status
celebrations now obviously postponed
the late queen granted city status and
this was the day when we were going to
have the formal official celebration to
mark that so we had a really big service
involved so
at this point on saturday morning we
were expecting the place to be sort of
full of people and full of
bustle what's the mood been like over
the last few days
it's just been a sort of yeah almost a
sense of unreality that we can't quite
take it in because she's been such a
constant for the whole of our lives
really
wrexham has a royal pedigree
even if history hasn't always been kind
to the place itself
at wrexham they started a tour of a
thoroughly depressed area where the old
heavy industries have failed and a
desperate attempt is being made to
attract new companies specifically in
light industry
things have been changing pretty fast
here in wrexham the town becoming a city
its football team getting taken over by
hollywood actor ryan reynolds and now on
thursday in that moment that the queen
died wrexham and indeed the whole of
wales got a new prince and princess
alison williams met princess diana here
in 1991 and now welcomes her son prince
william and his wife taking on the role
i think william and kate are amazing
i think they will make a brilliant
prince princess of wales it's nice that
they lived here for so long
it means that they're interested and
they understand more about wales
the new prince and princess of wales
also bring with them this
a way of operating online that's as
slick as in real life
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck tonight
but in a moment where the monarchy is
looking to its future for some even
these social media savvy younger royals
feel somewhat distant
on their instagram they post all these
pretty things this stuff neither we
didn't get to see that it would be
impossible for them to feel relatable to
anyone in our generation at the very
least anyway because of the struggles
we're having with the inflation and like
living crisis you know they don't have
to deal with that as much as ocelot
that's what we all want as a country we
want them to bring
the uk into the new generation and be
more relatable he's got a look back to
his grandfather and his father's
footsteps for instance she got the duke
of edinburgh award and then the prince's
trust award
in the moment the queen died royal role
shifted titles changed but the
responsibility remains to engage the
public and preserve a legacy
kashmir totsi sky news in wrexham
[Music]
now members of the royal family who
remain at balmoral greeted the crowds
that were gathered outside the estate
this afternoon they had attended a
private prayer service at crafty kirk
that is the church visited by the queen
during her holidays many of them that
she took there in scotland the family
then spent time looking at the flowers
and of course reading the letters that
were left by the public following the
queen's death on thursday
some
were visibly upset as they read the
tributes
well greg milam is at balmoral
for us um
greg we've seen the crowds amassing
coming to pay their respects but they've
also been hoping for a glimpse haven't
they of some of the members of the royal
family so that they can express their
condolences to them we saw here in
windsor the two brothers of course
william prince william prince of wales
and his brother the duke of sussex
accompanied by their wives spent 40
minutes
walking through the crowds and thanking
them for their good wishes and their
condolences on the death of their
grandmother her majesty the queen tell
us what was happening up in balmoral
yeah well it was those other members of
the royal family of course gathered here
on on thursday and all of those
uncertain moments and have been here
ever since uh the king's three siblings
of course uh their partners their
children uh and for the hundreds of of
people who today again have been filing
uh through here to lay flowers to leave
messages just to look at the other
tributes i think it was a significant
moment
to see for the first time those members
of the royal family travel the short
distance to crafty church for a private
uh family service that took place there
and then to make the decision to walk
back
to engage with those who were lining the
barriers here across the bridge into the
estate uh to say a few words to thank
them for coming
and then as you say to look at those
flowers and tributes and it was very
clear from from watching that how moved
some were the duke of york uh hugging
his daughter eugenie as she wiped away a
tear looking at some of those some of
those messages and then applause from
from those who were here
as the family made their way uh back
into back into the estate and prepared
for what comes next and remember how
many of those people who are here uh to
lay tributes are people who live in the
area live in these villages who regard
the queen as a neighbor a member of
their community and why it was so
special i think for them
to see the members of her family and to
see that response from them and those
those members of the community now know
what happens next and that the the
queen's body will leave here at 10
o'clock tomorrow morning and we'll pass
on a journey to edinburgh through some
of those communities that meant so much
to the queen throughout her life and
again that will be an opportunity for
those communities those neighbors
um to pay their tributes as the queen
makes her final journey from balmoral
down to edinburgh
greg for now thank you
now the queen was revered around the
world but she always had a special place
in her heart for the commonwealth our
communities correspondent lisa holland
has been speaking to some of those from
commonwealth countries who've made
britain their home
we all call you grandma yes
in south london friends and family call
louise the queen of brixton
not just because she's a
great-great-grandmother who fostered
more than 20 children but at 96 years of
age she was born on exactly the same day
as queen elizabeth ii
they call you the queen of brixton i
hear yes yes yes when
i had birthday
comes up at that time i said
is the queen birthday and from me too
louise came to britain as part of the
windrush generation
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set but as she watched the
proclamation of a new king she recalled
the late queen visiting jamaica in the
1950s the waves talk
to everyone i will beware back
in multicultural brixton scratch the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the queen's decades of
global commonwealth tours
when i was at school when i remember the
helicopter land
at the back of the school i'm sierra
from that um no it's not the time for
morning
now is the time to celebrate the lady
life she'll live our life to the marks
she saw what made everyone feel like
part of the commonwealth part of
britain you know so i just think that
the world's a poorer place without her
what's also clear is just how
significant the queen's global influence
and standing was in so many countries
around the world
there is no
queen anywhere else like only united
kingdom
in this fabric shop we met bill al who
said it was watching the queen from a
young age which inspired him to want to
move to the uk from india nearly 20
years ago you always heard about the
news like queen sometime picture come in
on the newspaper what's it like
michael who grew up in ghana says the
queen's legacy will live on
she's a very strong brand now we've got
a king she might probably follow the
same footsteps that the mum left behind
britain's new king already has the good
will of those who revered his mother to
help build his own future as monarch
lisa holland sky news south london
now princess elizabeth as she then was
was in kenya when she learned that her
father george vi had died and she had
become queen she then ascended to the
throne on the steps of the state house
in nairobi following a proclamation in
the kenyan capital alastair bunkel sent
this report from nairobi
kenya is where the reign of queen
elizabeth started but her death has
stirred mixed emotions for a country
that didn't always have the easiest
relationship with the late modern
in 1952 the then princess elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
prince philip her trip was cut short
when her father king george vi
unexpectedly died
the young princess became queen whilst
on kenyan land a date that many still
fondly remember
in nairobi's rail museum the queen's
royal visits are celebrated
so when she visited kenya in 1993 she
used the royal trail
on her
you've got er there elizabeth regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in kenya during that
time
and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history britain's
colonial rule the british crackdown on
the mao mao uprising killed an estimated
11 000 kenyans and many held the queen
as britain's head of state responsible
kenya was colonized by by the british
and being colonized by the british
people have lost their fathers they have
lost their grandparents here fighting
for independence fighting for
independence from the colonies so again
when this is a colonizer there are
people who that is the feeling they have
the association with the queen has also
had some positives yes yes their
positives i mean the colonization also
brought positive things but again
there's the negativity bit of the losses
that kenya as a people went through
signs of british colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
elizabeth highway when it opened but
since renamed freedom road after
independence
time has healed only so much here
king charles ascended to the throne
replacing the mother this in itself
marks a new beginning i don't think
a great fraction of kenyans will look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical
will still continue to post their hard
and uncomfortable questions and will
demand
economic justice
political justice and reparations
britain and kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
commonwealth
but a new king
won't necessarily be a new beginning
alice to bungle sky news in nairobi
well the legacy of her majesty the queen
felt all over the world not least
here in windsor one of their favorite
residents of her majesty where she spent
a lot of time in the latter years of her
life well-wishers have come out in their
crowds here to come and pay their
respects and they were treated to an
appearance of not just prince william
prince of wales and princess princess of
wales princess catherine but also the
duke and duchess of sussex who mingled
amongst the crowds thanking them
for coming out to pay their respects
they spent 40 minutes talking to them
here on the day that their father king
charles iii was officially proclaimed
king
back to you mark
sam thank you very much indeed and just
a few moments ago we saw king charles
drive out of buckingham palace and stop
a few hundred yards
along the mall and then
uh walk into the crowds he got out of
the car and walked
into the crowd now these are
uh the pictures
that we brought you earlier and these
are the latest pictures that we can show
you the
queen consort
meeting the crowds
with uh
king charles and uh these scenes just
off the mall just
a wave now oh these are pictures from
claret's house i'm being told so these
are
pictures
uh from clarence house
queen camilla we saw her
earlier today at the proclamation of
king charles and these
are the pictures of the king as he got
out of his car
and went to meet crowds yet again
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
king charles uh
arrived back at buckingham palace
yesterday and got out of his car and
went to uh look at the floral tributes
and
again shake hands and
talk to people uh who have
come in their constant stream to
uh buckingham palace and still they come
and this was
this was just a few moments ago when
when he drove out uh from buckingham
palace to clarence house and he's back
out with
the people
well outside of the uk the war in
ukraine has seen a major development
today with ukrainian forces making gains
uh some considerable gains in the east
of the country russia's defense ministry
has said it's pulling back troops
from key areas in ukraine's harkiv
region
russia is said to have been taken by
surprise as ukraine has made these
advances in the east of the country
ukraine launched its counter-offensive
into those russian-held territories in
the east earlier
this week the attack is said to have
left thousands of russian troops
increasingly isolated
near the key city of isiam
you see there
yesterday evening president zielenski
said ukraine had retaken 30 settlements
in the haki region sky's defense and
security editor debra haynes has this
report from eastern ukraine
this is the gateway to a key city that
russian forces captured in the first
weeks of the war
but these are ukrainian troops
they're part of a lightning advance
retaking swathes of territory across the
kharkiv region
seemingly beating the russians into
retreat
in order to achieve the stated goals of
the special military operation to
liberate donbass a decision was made to
regroup the russian troops stationed
about clear and isiam regions to build
up our efforts in the direction of the
nets
regrouping sounds more like retreating
to reinforce russia's positions in the
crucial donbass region
the sudden russian order came after
ukrainian troops retook the small city
of balaklia a couple of days earlier the
national flag flying high once more
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclava the first major city in our
offensive i'm sure that it will not be
our last
russia's worst nightmare appears to be
unfolding in eastern ukraine
these pictures were taken from the city
of kupiansk
recapturing this place would deal a
significant blow to russia as it's been
an important supply route to support
russian forces in donbass
russia's decision to pull back some
forces from eastern positions is
extraordinary but ukraine is also waging
counter-attacks from the south the
simultaneous operations backed by
western weapons mark the biggest
ukrainian offensive of the war and could
be a key turning point if the gains are
sustained
[Music]
for those who've spent months under
russian occupation the relief is all too
clear to see
they've waited a long time for this
haynes sky news in eastern ukraine
let's return to events here now and the
queen became a cultural icon and
maintained britain's image around the
world sky's arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer has this
report
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous her
image at the core of british culture
the queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premiere of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she'd play in maintaining
the allure of brand britain
i remember when i was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
prince philip who was about the best
looking man
in the world i mean everybody at school
had a crush on him and i kept scrapbooks
of the queen everything that was in the
papers or the magazines i cut out and it
was um princess elizabeth's wedding and
she was a fairy tale princess she really
was she was gorgeous she had a hand span
waist big wonderful eyes we all just
loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her platinum jubilee
um
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich i
always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the relentless public
infatuation with this woman
if you imagine i'm going to drop
everything and come down to london
before i attend to my grandchildren
who've just lost their mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
lucian freud to andy warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her legacy
i remember when i was first commissioned
it was a daunting prospect you know the
queen the most portrayed woman in
history i asked if man would like to
rest in between shots
that'd be fine just conscious of all the
light onto her so
she closed her eyes and
that was the moment it was you know
it didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at
sitting for artists was part of her
cultural duty but she also inspired some
significant unofficial art an
anti-establishment target epitomized on
the cover of the 1977 sex pistols single
her defaced lightness and easy act of
rebellion
if you went to most west indians home at
the time they would probably have a
picture of the queen on a wall as well
as a picture of jesus
while rock photographer dennis morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the queen's
silver jubilee he was following the
pistol's provocative boat trip on the
thames
at that time
the monarchy was very very strong we
were not particularly liked for being
anti-monarchy in that sense as i grew
older and knew more and more about it i
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot
to hold something like that together the
way she has over the years so you know
for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many british artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
arts for those who embraced her
magisterial authority or rebelled
against it she inspired
her influence over british culture
irrefutable and unique
thank you
pull everything
that's very kind
katie spencer sky news
good evening from buckingham palace on
the day when charles iii was officially
proclaimed king
the palace confirms the queen state
funeral will be held on monday september
the 19th with the day declared a bank
holiday
the united front the prince of wales
pays tribute to his grandmother and
makes a surprise appearance in windsor
alongside princess catherine prince
harry and megan
king charles was confirmed at an ancient
ceremony the accession council which was
televised for the very first time
in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray
for the guidance and help of almighty
god
watching on some of the most senior
figures in the country including every
living prime minister
[Music]
the gun salutes rang out across the
united kingdom in honor of the new king
the prime minister and other mps swear
their allegiance to the king in a rare
saturday sitting at the house of commons
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening from buckingham palace
where tonight we've learned details of
how the nation will mourn the queen over
the next few days
this afternoon king charles met senior
political figures in the building in the
building behind me after a special
ceremony earlier which officially
proclaimed him king
and in windsor the new prince and
princess of wales greeted well wishes
along with the duke and duchess of
sussex
more on that in a moment but first
here's our first report from our royal
correspondent ran on mills
it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual that was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start
and now the end of the second
elizabethan age
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
as politicians past and present
of all political persuasions including
every former living prime minister
gathered inside st james's palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy councillors
to acknowledge formally the change of
rain
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
and of his other realms and territories
king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith god save the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by king charles
his heir and queen consort close by
as we were all able to witness a moment
never seen before
a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting
personally declaring his intention to
serve
my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you
the entire nation and i think i may say
the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we've all
suffered
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication
and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks for this most faithful
life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
and in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray for the guidance and help
of almighty god
it's the personal touches his family
around him the inkwell on the table
given him as a gift by prince william
and prince harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives of the commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much
her majesty the queen had given us but
also
welcoming the new king
and for the new king charles to make
those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way i think was moving for
everyone and it is a moment i'm sure no
one in that room will ever forget
[Music]
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
echoed in the city of london as the
second proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal exchange
god save the king
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the united kingdom
for now buckingham palace remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the
mall but behind them a king who wants to
be seen
who wants us to understand what we're
now witnessing as like us he's quickly
had to adjust
rihanna mills sky news at st james's
palace
well today the prince of wales has said
it will take some time before the
reality of life without granny will
truly feel real as he paid tribute to
the queen in his first public statement
since her death william who's become
heir to the throne after the accession
of his father king charles said the
queen was by his side at my happiest
moments and during the saddest days of
my life
and this afternoon the prince and
princess of wales and the duke and
duchess of sussex have greeted crowds on
a surprise walkabout in windsor
my colleague sam washington is there and
we can speak to her now and it was truly
a surprise for those crowds that have
been waiting patiently there sam
jillian i know you have throngs there
you've had them there all day from very
early hours of this morning people who
wanted to observe at some of the
official proceedings that were taking
place however there's still crowds
coming here in their masses to windsor
of course recognizing that windsor was
one of the favorite residences of her
majesty the queen and indeed of the
royal family people coming here to pay
their respects to her majesty and also
to think about the new era now under
king charles iii also hoping very much
to get a glimpse of some members of the
royal family and they were not to be
disappointed not only did they get to
see as you can see here on the screen
there the new prince and princess of
wales prince william and princess
catherine and surprise
was of course to also see the duke and
duchess of sussex they arrived at about
quarter past five this afternoon both
getting out of separate cars there
beginning to walk down the long walk
there that they know uh so well it's
been so uh influential uh this
royal residence here i've been the
backdrop of many happy an occasion
not least the wedding of the duke and
duchess of sussex they both went to
different sides there to go and greet
the well-wishers most of the images
that we have are of
uh prince william and princess catherine
but you can see there
as well prince harry
he cut a very solemn figure didn't he
when he was departing balmoral
by himself having missed the chance to
say goodbye to his grandmother her
majesty
here he is now
seemingly putting differences with his
brother aside to both
walk either side there of the long
sidings there of people who've come
to pay their respects very generous with
their time often these walkabouts only
last uh
five ten minutes or so forty minutes
they worked their way
through the crowd shaking hands you can
see there princess catherine stopping to
talk to many children and babies prince
william there receiving a little
paddington bear which because of the
recent
film that we saw with her majesty and
paddington uh is very poignant of course
that statement julian that you were
referring to which prince william had
decided to wait and reflect on his
feelings before
releasing in which he said he i have
lost a grandmother and while i will
grieve her loss i also feel incredibly
grateful i have had the benefit of the
queen's wisdom and reassurance into my
fifth decade and my wife too has had 20
years of her guidance and support my
three children have got to spend
holidays with her and create memories
that will last their whole lives a very
personal and poignant also informal
statement there from the new prince of
wales but well-wishers were rewarded for
their patience and waiting today because
they got to see not only
the prince of wales their heir of course
now to the throne and princess catherine
but also his brother the the duke of
sussex and his wife the duchess of
sussex they're reunited uh seen together
uh for the first time after a long while
but seemingly putting their differences
apart for the sake of commemorating
their grandmother her majesty the queen
and also to commemorate the ascension to
the throne of their father now king
charles iii back to you
sam thank you yes those crowds are
delighted to see them
wrexham in north wales was due to be
celebrating its recent award of city
status as part of the queen's platinum
jubilee celebrations earlier this year
indeed its residents are coming to terms
with the death of the monarch and the
beginning of a new era of royal rule
sky's correspondent katarina vertopsi
explores the bonds between the royal
family and this part of north wales and
speaks to the people there about the
next generation
of royals
[Music]
today in wrexham as church bells rang
out to mark king charles's accession
inside a model of the late queen's crown
came down
there was meant to be a party here today
to mark wrexham getting city status
celebrations now obviously
postponed the late queen granted city
status and this was the day when we were
going to have the uh formal official
celebration to mark that so we had a
really big service involved so
at this point on saturday morning we
were expecting the place to be sort of
full of people and full of
bustle what's the mood been like over
the last few days
it's just been a sort of yeah almost a
sense of unreality that we can't quite
take it in because she's been such a
constant for the whole of our lives
really wrexham has a royal pedigree
even if history hasn't always been kind
to the place itself
at wrexham they started a tour of a
thoroughly depressed area where the old
heavy industries have failed and a
desperate attempt is being made to
attract new companies specifically in
light industry
things have been changing pretty fast
here in wrexham the town becoming a city
it's football team getting taken over by
hollywood actor ryan reynolds and now on
thursday in that moment that the queen
died wrexham and indeed the whole of
wales got a new prince and princess
alison williams met princess diana here
in 1991 and now welcomes her son prince
william and his wife taking on the role
i think william and kate are amazing
i think they will make a brilliant
prince princess of wales it's nice that
they lived here for so long
it means that they're interested and
they understand
more about wales
the new prince and princess of wales
also bring with them this
[Music]
a way of operating online that's as
slick as in real life
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck tonight
but in a moment where the monarchy is
looking to its future for some even
these social media savvy younger royals
feel somewhat distant
on their instagram they post all these
pretty things they're starting we didn't
get to see that it would be impossible
for them to feel relatable to anyone in
our generation at the very least anyway
because of the struggles we're having
with the inflation and like living
crisis you know they don't have to deal
with that as much as a slot that's what
we all want as a country we want them to
bring the uk into the new generation and
be more relatable he's got a look back
to his grandfather and his father's
footsteps for instance she got the duke
of edinburgh award and then the prince's
trust award
in the moment the queen died royal roles
shifted
titles changed but the responsibility
remains to engage the public and
preserve a legacy
catering over totsi sky news in wrexham
well the queen was revered around the
world but she always had a special place
in her heart for the commonwealth our
community's correspondent lisa holland
has been speaking to some of those from
commonwealth countries who've made
britain their home we'll call you
grandma yes
in south london friends and family call
louise the queen of brixton
not just because she's a great great
grandmother who fostered more than 20
children but at 96 years of age she was
born on exactly the same day as queen
elizabeth ii
they call you the queen of brixton i
hear yes yes
yes well
i had birthday
comes up at that time i said
he's the queen birthday and for me too
i'm feeling good
louise came to britain as part of the
windrush generation
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set but as she watched the
proclamation of a new king she recalled
the late queen visiting jamaica in the
fifties it waved off
to everyone and we've revealed back
in multicultural brixton scratch the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the queen's decades of
global commonwealth tours
when i was at school when i remember the
helicopter land
at the back of the school i'm sierra
from that um no it's not the time for
morning
now is the time to celebrate
the lady life she'll live our life to
the marks she's always made everyone
feel like
part of the commonwealth part of
brit you know so i just think like the
world's a poorer place without her
what's also clear is just how
significant the queen's global influence
and standing was in so many countries
around the world there's no
queen anywhere else like only united
kingdom
in this fabric shop we met bill al who
said it was watching the queen from a
young age which inspired him to want to
move to the uk from india nearly 20
years ago we always heard about the news
like queen sometime picture come in on
the newspaper what's it like
michael who grew up in ghana says the
queen's legacy will live on it's a very
strong brand now we've got a king she
might probably follow the same footsteps
that the mum left behind
britain's new king already has the good
will of those who revered his mother to
help build his own future as monarch
lisa holland sky news south london
well let's cross to melinda vasilenovich
now who spent the day amongst the crowds
here at uh buckingham palace and milan
surprisingly people are still coming
people are still coming in their
thousands really it's got even busier
here within the last hour or so you can
see this area here has really become a
focal point for people to come together
take a moment to reflect and think about
what the queen
meant to them and we can now speak to
one of the families that were here today
the samu family who have come together
uh to really share in the collective
feeling and grief over the queen's death
tell me why why did you guys feel that
you wanted to come here today
just to pay our respects because she was
a very humble
she was nice she was
kind caring she was a nice queen all
together
um even though we never got to meet her
she would what she did for everyone
around the world was very nice and and
what did the queen mean to you
um i mean she meant a lot to me but she
was so like down to earth whatever she
did she thought about the country first
like doing that for 70 years non-stop is
a lot and she just meant
like a lot a huge amount to me
and you've come down here as well with
your family the queen has been the
constant throughout your life you're
very young how do you feel now of the
prospect of her being gone
it is a bit well
it's quite shocking really because we
were born into this world into this
country when she was she was on top
really we've known only her as the queen
like ruling mona and now now she's gone
it is quite it's quite you feel it
really quite a lot
and finding mom and dad why did you feel
compelled to come here today
with your family
yeah um when your news broke all the
children in the house they were crying
and it was on my birthday as well and
they were all crying tears the whole
house and as a veteran of the british
army i swore allegiance to the queen as
well so it means so much to us and we we
follow the royal family we are
we are very very very much part of the
royal family and part of everything that
the establishment stand for so it's
personal to us and we just want to come
here to pay our respect to um ask god to
send our angels to you know take her
into heaven and be in a very happy place
and finally the fact that you're here
with other people sharing in your
emotion does that bring any comfort to
you
oh yeah definitely um we feel much
better that we're here even though we we
cannot see any of the royal family
members but we are happy that we can
make it and also we're looking forward
to come for the funeral
yeah
thank you very much for talking to sky
news so really a lot of outpouring of
emotions still here people coming laying
flowers laying tributes and the weight
of history really felt here by
buckingham palace now
thank you people still wanting to to
come and be a part of
what is happening here today at
buckingham palace well during her
70-year reign the queen became a
cultural icon and maintained britain's
image around the world
she inspired artists and awarded
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
and her platinum jubilee attracted
record audiences as people around the uk
celebrated after the challenges of the
pandemic
sky's arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer reports now
on the queen's cultural significance
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous her
image at the core of british culture
the queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premiere of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she played in maintaining
the allure of brand britain
i remember when i was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
prince philip who was about the best
looking man
in the world i mean everybody at school
had a crush on him and i kept scrapbooks
of the queen everything that was in the
papers or the magazines i cut out and it
was
princess elizabeth's wedding and she was
a fairy tale princess she really was she
was gorgeous she had a hand span waist
big wonderful eyes we all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her platinum jubilee
um
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the relentless public
infatuation with this woman
if you imagine i'm going to drop
everything and come down to london
before i attend to my grandchildren who
just lost their mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
lucian freud to andy warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her legacy
i remember when i was first commissioned
it was a daunting prospect you know the
queen the most portrayed woman in
history i asked if man would like to
rest in between shots
that'd be fine just conscious of all the
light onto her so
she closed her eyes and that was the
moment it was you know
it didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at
sitting for artists was part of her
cultural duty but she also inspired some
significant unofficial art an
anti-establishment target epitomized on
the cover of the 1977 sex pistols single
a defaced lightness and easy act of
rebellion
if you went to most west indians home at
the time they would probably have a
picture of the queen on the wall as well
as a picture of jesus
while rock photographer dennis morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the queen's
silver jubilee he was following the
pistols provocative boat trip on the
thames
at that time the monarchy was very very
strong we were
not particularly liked for being
anti-monarchy in that sense as i grew
older and knew more and more about it i
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot
to hold something like that together the
way she has over the years so you know
for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many british artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
arts for those who embraced her
magisterial authority or rebelled
against it she inspired her influence
over british culture irrefutable and
unique
thank you
call everything
that's very kind
katie spencer sky news
and just to let you know that at eight
o'clock trevor phillips looks back at
how britain has changed during her
majesty's reign in a special documentary
the queen's people
and tonight and every night at nine
o'clock you'll have another chance to
see trevor with the highlights of the
day's events he'll be presenting a royal
special the death of the queen live
here from buckingham palace
the house of commons is sitting this
evening for a second day of tributes
from mps to the queen
senior members have also been swearing
the oath of allegiance to king charles
iii
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare an affair that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law
i do swear that i will be faithful and
be of true allegiance to his majesty ken
charles his hairs and successors
according to lord it's the help of god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord
so help meet god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and fair true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successes according to law so helpful
well actually political correspondent
john craig is in westminster and mp's
wearing their allegiance there but john
you've got some news regarding uh
politics and the royal tour
downing street has announced tonight
that liz trusts will accompany king
charles and camilla are on a tour of the
uk which begins next week now first of
all uh here in westminster uh the king
is coming to westminster uh to meet mps
to make an address to them according to
the official announcement
the both houses of parliament will meet
in westminster hall to express their
condolences and the king will make his
reply now after that uh we've been told
by the palace that the king and queen
consort are going to edinburgh to the
scottish parliament they're going to
meet the first minister uh going to
do various political and constitutional
events in edinburgh
then on tuesday it's northern ireland
and it's hillsborough and meeting with
party leaders there
wales friday um but um
the news from number 10 is that the
prime minister is accompanying them uh
now that's this has raised a few uh
eyebrows amongst politicians um who
will uh wonder why that the queen the
prime minister needs to accompany the
king and queen the answer from downing
street is that uh as to support the king
at what the downing street is calling a
significant moment of national mourning
so that's next week here in westminster
uh preparations are already underway for
the queen lying in state that starts on
wednesday there's all sorts of building
work going on outside uh for uh
for people to queue and so on getting
westminster hall ready um big crowds are
expected i remember back in i think it
was 2000 when the queen mother died the
crowds were vastly bigger than the
authorities thought they would be
queueing all around the block in
westminster so they'll be having seen
the crowds we've seen over the last
couple of days outside buckingham palace
i think we can safely say there'll be
massive cues for people to see the queen
lying in state now as for what's
happened here today um
after those oaths that we saw that was
the beginning of proceedings at one
o'clock the tributes continued uh the
speaker announced that uh yesterday
they're 182 from mps well they started
today with therese coffee with a number
of ministers speaking from the back
benches lots of anecdotes uh various
ministers and ex-ministers talking about
their embarrassment at
various privy council functions and so
on um
funny story from yvette cooper about
claire shorts mobile phone going off
during a privy council meeting and the
queen saying hope that wasn't anyone
important uh in the house of lords
meanwhile we had baroness shackleton
fiona shackleton the solicitor who acted
in the charles and andrew divorces she
was giving her tribute we had alex
sharma hoping for uh her legacy the
queen's legacy on the cop 26 to be
continued by uh uh by the king charles
we heard from john whittingdale about
what he called robust discussions
between margaret thatcher for whom he
then worked and the queen during their
weekly audiences we've also had claims
from mps uh the mp for morecambe saying
that the queen was a fan of morkum and
wise and also the cone valley mp she was
a fan of uh last of the summer wine so
those uh continue tonight will be what's
called a humble address to her man his
majesty and that's basically emotion
pledging loyalty and a allegiance but a
lot happening next week including that
tour by the king queen consul and indeed
the prime minister to scotland wales and
northern ireland
okay john thank you
well with the passing of her majesty the
queen some sporting events were
cancelled today as a mark of respect
however some did go ahead with those
present taking the opportunity to pay
tribute to the queen as a collective rob
harris reports
across the commonwealth and around the
world
cricket returning with solemnity and
silence
players and fans bonded by sport uniting
at the oval to mourn their monarch
[Music]
a rendition of god save the king the
first broadcaster a sporting event since
the accession of charles before the
delayed start of england's test against
south africa
cricket resuming while some other sports
remain suspended in britain
the powerful tributes here at the oval
showed why cricket leaders wanted their
sport to resume to honor they said the
life and service of the queen she wants
to use her christmas broadcast to talk
about the power of sporting being able
to bring people together
and we've seen here just how that can
take place
horse racing the sporting passion of
queen elizabeth resumes across britain
on sunday but football chose to pause
throughout the weekend
i personally wouldn't have wanted to
play i'd wanted two or three days just
to reflect uh and think about um all the
wonderful things she's done
food destined for premier league
stadiums like liverpool donated to food
banks a decision is yet to be taken and
whether domestic football is played next
weekend before the funeral
in golf play at the pga championship at
wentworth was suspended following the
queen's death on thursday
was started on saturday after the
government left it at the discretion of
each sport whether to hold events
rugby union had split decisions across
the united kingdom with the games only
in england this weekend the great north
run going ahead on sunday in what
organizers call a subdued form
at the cricket in london those no longer
able to play sport this weekend taking
the chance to pay respect
i was like football but happy to come
here to watch the break when kind of
everyone just went silent and that was
unprompted it was uh yeah it was quite
special a bit emotional got a little bit
choked up after the mix i'm a monarchist
just having brought up you know what i
believe and
i thought it was really moving actually
yes in a nation grieving sport bringing
people together to express condolences
and gratitude to the queen's service and
reign rob harris sky news the oval
well as well as being queen of the
united kingdom elizabeth ii was of
course queen of the commonwealth despite
a growing republican movement in
australia her death has overwhelmingly
been met with sorrow cordelia lynch
reports from sydney
[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the queen once walked her son must
now follow and here in australia it is a
turning point
we just loved her we just loved it the
older we got
the more we could relate to her because
she felt like she was just always there
for us i'm just like a lot of other
older australians we're just grieving
because
she was the queen of australia a lot of
people that's lost on a lot of people it
felt like um the queen was almost um
immortal at some point you know she
she's lived a long time and
yeah i mean even
though she
was quite old when she passed it still
came as a shock
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit these shores
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population spellbound
i want to tell you all
how happy i am to be amongst you
and how much i look forward to my
journey through australia
such outbursts of spontaneous affection
she loves this country she loved this
country i should say
she'd been here 16 times and you don't
do that if you don't like the place and
she came back again and again and again
and she found the same thing again and
again again warmth affection
i think she really admired the
resilience of australians
who work and live off the land here it's
very nice to see you in person this time
yes your majesty
scott morrison admired her ability to
make light work of calming his nerves
she had he says a regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see alike again but
we won't
where do you see that relationship
with the crown going there does remain a
strong connection and an appreciation
i mean our success in australia is in no
small part
due to the stability of our democracy of
our constitutional system
and the crown sits at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic
and that conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that
feels strikingly rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen that appears enduring
sky news sydney australia
to some other news now and outside of
the uk the war in ukraine has seen a
major development today with ukrainian
forces making gains in the east of the
country russia's defense ministry has
said it's pulling back troops from key
areas in ukraine's harkief region
russia is said to have been taken by
surprise as ukraine has made advances in
the east of the country
ukraine launched its counter-offensive
in the east earlier this week in a daily
update uk defence officials said
ukraine's forces have made advances in
around 31 miles into previously
russian-held territory
the attack is said to have left
thousands of russian troops increasingly
isolated near the key city of israel
the offensive is now seeking to sever
the russian supply lines near cupianze
and trap thousands of troops in israel
yesterday evening president vladimir
zelensky said ukraine had retaken 30
settlements in the haki region our
defense and security editor deborah
haynes has this report from eastern
ukraine
this is the gateway to a key city that
russian forces captured in the first
weeks of the war
but these are ukrainian troops
they're part of a lightning advance
retaking swathes of territory across the
kharkiv region
seemingly beating the russians into
retreat
in order to achieve the stated goals of
the special military operation to
liberate donbass a decision was made to
regroup the russian troops stationed
about a clear and isiam regions to build
up our efforts in the direction of the
nets
regrouping sounds more like retreating
to reinforce russia's positions in the
crucial donbass region
the sudden russian order came after
ukrainian troops retook the small city
of balaklia a couple of days earlier the
national flag flying high once more
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclava the first major city in our
offensive i'm sure that it will not be
our last
russia's worst nightmare appears to be
unfolding in eastern ukraine
these pictures were taken from the city
of kupiansk
recapturing this place would deal a
significant blow to russia as it's been
an important supply route to support
russian forces in donbass
russia's decision to pull back some
forces from eastern positions is
extraordinary but ukraine is also waging
counter-attacks from the south the
simultaneous operations backed by
western weapons mark the biggest
ukrainian offensive of the war and could
be a key turning point if the games are
sustained
for those who've spent months under
russian occupation the relief is all too
clear to see
they've waited a long time for this
debrahing sky news in eastern ukraine
[Music]
the family of a 24 year old man shot
dead by armed metropolitan police have
called for the officer involved to be
immediately suspended whilst at a march
today in his memory
the firearms officer who shot chris
cabarr in south london on monday is
currently subject to a homicide
investigation
family and friends of mr campbell
gathered in westminster today to walk in
his memory and protest police brutality
rapper stormzy spoke at the march
i just encourage everyone in whatever
capacity do whatever you can to help
that whatever you can do with coming to
this march but it's these amazing people
here
directly do whatever you can but also
just have to summon us and keep down
is
[Music]
[Music]
news the family's three demands to the
metropolitan police force
so the first demand for the family is
that we want to know if the officer
involved has been suspended um secondly
we want body cam footage of the incident
released to the family and then finally
we want to have a timeline of how long
the investigation will take
that's the free demands and that's the
three demands that everyone came out
here to support
well let's return now to the momentous
events of the past couple of days since
the death of the late queen princess
elizabeth as she was then was in kenya
when she learned that her father george
vi had died and she become queen she
then ascended to the throne on the steps
of the state house in nairobi following
a proclamation in the kenyan capital
similar to those which have taken place
across the commonwealth today for her
son charles iii
as de bunkel sent this report from
nairobi
kenya is where the reign of queen
elizabeth started but her death has
stirred mixed emotions for a country
that didn't always have the easiest
relationship with the late
in 1952 the then princess elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
prince philip her trip was cut short
when her father king george vi
unexpectedly died
the young princess became queen whilst
on kenyon land a date that many still
fondly remember in nairobi's rail museum
the queen's royal visits are celebrated
so when she visited kenya in 1993 she
used the world trade
on her way through nanuki
you've got er there elizabeth regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in kenya during that
time
and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history
britain's colonial rule the british
crackdown on the mao mao uprising killed
an estimated 11 000 kenyans and many
held the queen as britain's head of
state responsible kenya was colonized by
by the british and being colonized by
the british people have lost their
fathers they have lost their
grandparents here fighting for
independence fighting for independence
from the colonies
so again when this is a colonizer
they're people who that is the feeling
they have wow the association with the
queen has also had some positives yes
yes they're positives i mean the
colonization also brought positive
things but again there's the negativity
bit of the losses that kenya as a people
went through
signs of british colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
elizabeth highway when it opened but
since renamed freedom road after
independence
time has healed only so much here
king charles ascended to the throne
replacing the mother this in itself
marks a new beginning i don't think
a great fraction of kenyans will look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical
will still continue to pose their hard
and uncomfortable questions and will
demand
economic justice
political justice and reparations
britain and kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
commonwealth
but a new king
won't necessarily be a new beginning
alistair bundle sky news in nairobi
well let's speak now to grant harold
former butler and a member of the royal
household the royal highnesses the
prince of wales and the duchess of
cornwall he's in highgrove and we can
speak to him now good evening to you i
understand you're speaking to us from
your cottage in the grounds of highgrove
good evening yes yes i am i noticed
today
driving past obviously the main entrance
that now floral tributes are now being
laid at the gates and obviously people
are looking at them which is quite
emotional to see because there's quite a
few quite a few being put down now
tell us about your your role as this
former butler what was it like working
for the royal household
it for me it was a dream come true when
i was a youngster or a teenager i
remember seeing a documentary about the
roth family and the queen and i said to
my father how do you
work or become part of that my father
said you either marry into them or you
work for them and i thought well who
could i who could i marry with my first
thought and then lastly realized that
working funnels it was a sensible option
uh and within about 11 years i made that
dream come true and ironically the
the one of the scenes in the the program
i watched you saw the queen dance and at
the ballroom in the morrow where she is
where her body is at rest of the moment
and
for me
which was extraordinary 11 years later i
was in that ballroom and i actually
danced
with the queen so i found it really
emotional when i discovered last night
that that's where the moment her body is
and just brought back so many um so many
wonderful memories
you've got to tell us a little bit more
about dancing with the queen
well
basically um the the actual evening of
the actual ball i remember i was i was
doing dinner for the then prince of
wales and he actually asked if i was
going to go to the the ball because he
he knew this the story and i i said that
i i actually said i forgot to bring i i
said i don't have anything to wear i
forgot when somebody i remember he said
oh you've got your kilt haven't you and
i said i have so i must have told them
and then i said having any weight can i
can't travel and that the duchess now
the queen said well you can go with us
and i thought why did i why did i not
think i could go and convoy with the raw
highnesses and sure enough we went over
to the castle and
when i went into the ballroom i was
amazed at how beautiful this room is
and
the national anthem played the queen
with other members of our family walked
into the room and then duchess of como
came to find me as she had actually
promised she would dance with me and
when we were dancing i
she said to me you're very nervous and i
told her the story about when i was
younger and i had this ambition to one
day dance with the queen and i said i'm
now really scared it's gonna happen and
she said well she's gone don't worry
there's 150 people in this room i'm sure
you'll be fine no sooner than she said
that
we the dance finished and i remember she
made this sound which made me think i
was standing on her on her feet and i
looked down and i looked back and she
kind of made this gestures look behind
you and i turned round and i i think i
kind of squeaked because the queen was
behind me and she suddenly kind of
raised her arms and said shall we and it
was
extraordinary and then she gathered
other members of the royal family we
went into a real
and
there's a part of the dance called a
dozie though and i did that with the
queen and
it was just extraordinary and the last
part of the dance you
something goes on and somebody goes over
and basically i was holding the dutch of
the coma's hand and i remember the
duchess almost kept the hand up which
meant the queen would go under and of
course the queen bows to nobody and i
remember the duchess looked at me all
day because i kind of yanked her hand a
little bit and she said to me are you
okay and i said your highness um the
queen would have had to invite them the
queen bows to nobody and i remember the
duchess going you're quite right i
probably saved the monarchy there um but
you know for me it was a it was an
absolute dream come true an absolute
dream come true and as i said so many
so many memories that have been kind of
flooding back to me over the special
over the last few days
that indeed is a very special one a
brilliant memory there and i do know
what
docido is and but tell us about the
first time
you met
the queen
the very first time oddly enough i was
on horseback and that's equally as an
embarrassing story that i think she
found quite amusing because i was a keen
horse rider when i was younger safe to
say i'm not any longer but back then i
was and i got the opportunity to go out
with some of actually the military
personnel who actually rode her her
ponies um
to keep them obviously exercised and she
was a very good rider i should mention
as well right up until recently until
the last few years
and i got the opportunity to go out and
we went out and towards the end of the
ride you come down to bermuda castle
most beautiful site and i remember as we
got near uh the kind of lawns the the
horses started acting strangely and i
panicked and which obviously you
shouldn't do and i thought there was
rabbits or something at the feet at the
the the hooves of the office of the
horses and i i can i said well there's
there's something here and kind of
panicked and the
the person that was kind of leading us
was kind of shaking ahead
violently as if they don't don't make
any sudden moves and i looked over and i
realized that it wasn't uh rabbits it
was coggies
and a little further away was this lady
little lady in a head scarf giggling
away um said oh i'm so sorry and called
the the dog the dogs back over and we
all kind of looked and i remember kind
of nodding my head because it's the
queen and just to give you a piece of
advice um it's not a good idea to try to
bow on a horse which i think she found
hysterical um and kind of went off and
kind of laughing so that was my my very
first encounter with with the queen and
a horse
you've got some wonderful stories um so
what was the the queen like in terms of
was she very different was the public
queen very different to the
the private i think as you you call her
mrs windsor
yes the reason i called her mrs windsor
was famously at memorial the cleveland
gown lodge where herself and her late
husband friends philip would spend a few
weeks before i don't know if people
realized that before the queen moved
into memorial she would spend a few
weeks privately on this little lodge and
it's where they got to be very much mr
and mrs windsor went back wednesday but
what i meant by that was mr and missy's
it was just them of course there was
those certain staff would go over and
assist and take things over but they
from what i was told uh because
obviously i wasn't there to see that
they would very much lay the tables he
would lay the table she would cook
but it didn't surprise me because prince
philip loves the barbecues and this
footage of them both helping each other
working together they were a real they
were team but the queen had this most
wonderful personality you know you see
the kind of the official side of it but
behind closed doors is i'm sure you've
heard many times she had this wonderful
personality she had this this great
humor her that she how she lit up her
room you walked in and just the way she
smiled her eyes she had this what i call
a granny glint when she looked at you
and she'd give you a smile and sometimes
a wink depending on something funny had
happened and you know and i remember the
only other thing i've got to say that i
remember shocking about the queen
once i kind of went and announced dinner
to the queen and we were walking along
this corridor and she started um running
and i'm sure there is footage obviously
the queen running she was i think very
good when she wanted to run and kind of
a very fast kind of fast very very fast
walk and i was trying to keep up with
her as she kind of started going and i
found myself almost running or kind of
trot and i don't know what to call it
and it was and i thought is this normal
is this what butler's doing and it was
just i think that was just i could have
you know she would do things unexpected
but i think it was the she did it for a
bit of fun i think it was a fun element
and i i loved that you know it's just
such a an unexpected side of it that i i
didn't think
grant harold thank you so much for
sharing your memories of the queen with
us good to speak to you thank you
well we can speak now to the
environmentalist and a long-standing
advisor to king charles on green issues
jonathan porritt welcome
to you um first of all tell us about
your working relationship with prince
charles as he was then king charles iii
now
he of course got interested in
environmental issues very early from
1970 onwards
and then began to take a more and more
public profile around many of the big
issues today i started working with him
in the 1980s as director of friends of
the earth and then through the whole of
the next 25 years basically at the time
when
many of the issues
which he had first picked up and most
people had chosen not to recognize
were becoming mainstream and i think
that was really important because he was
definitely a ahead of the game in that
respect
yes we hear that that a lot that he was
way ahead of his time in terms of
environmental issues and where would you
say that passion and interest came from
he would say that a lot of it
started with his own childhood i mean he
did have this unique privilege
he was brought up in beautiful places
with access to some amazing parts of
nature
and
i suppose he could have just taken that
for granted and not really thought about
it very much but he didn't it became an
absolutely essential foundation for
everything that he did after that and
then when he was in his early 20s he
began to think a lot
about the relationship between
humankind and the natural earth
and that then led on to all the
different causes the
the issues that he chose to surface to
advocate on behalf of to campaign for
you might say as the prince of wales
over
a 50-year period
and he's been quite vocal at times are
there certain issues that that you
recall where he has been particularly
vocal
yes he's been extremely vocal
he said what needed to be said
he said what a lot of politicians were
completely
incapable of giving voice to
he spoke a certain truth to them which
must have often been extremely
uncomfortable for them about issues like
the climate biodiversity
deforestation concerns about pollution
many politicians just want
put that on the back burner for as long
as they can get away with it and he was
trenchant in that commentary
so that is a legacy that he'll take with
him
a very different role of the
thing he will not be able to do what he
did a
principle
and he's made it very clear all the way
along
that he knew this moment would come
where his advocacy convening role would
change and he would move into the role
at a
constitutional
there's never been any doubt about any
doubt in his mind it was only a few
mischievous commentators who thought to
themselves will the prince of wales try
and carry that over
into his role as uh monarch well i can
assure you they were just stirring the
pot for the sake of it
yes he has acknowledged that his role um
must now change he's done that on more
than one occasion but his views
presumably won't change so what what
difference will we see might there be
behind the scenes workings
i'm sure there'll be i'm sure there'll
be a lot of behind the scenes stuff
going on absolutely but i have liked the
clarity with which he's helped everybody
to understand that he knows this
transition moment he understands the
difference between the prince of wales
being our constitutional monarch i
thought in his
first address to the nation where he
explained that he would be different it
was a bit like listening to somebody
saying
a farewell
to all of that campaigning work um
farewell and thanks for all the fish as
it were i'm now moving on to a different
job with different responsibilities but
don't think any of that passion
will die in him
as he changes his role it's just that he
will surface it
in different ways with other world
leaders with whoever happens to be the
prime minister of this country at any
time that he remains the the
constitutional monarch all of these
things will still be part and parcel
of the leadership that he brings to bear
on his new role
do you think he might still seek your
advice on environmental issues
one thing about
charles when he was the prince of wales
and i'm certain now as he is king
charles iii is that he's always sought
out advice from many
different sources he likes the diversity
of opinion he likes to hear people
discuss things disagree with each other
try and settle in the place that makes
most sense to him given his very deep
philosophical and spiritual underpinning
in this whole environment debate so i
can guarantee that he will still be out
there jonathan speaking diverse voices
we must leave it there thank you so much
for speaking to us jonathan pirate there
well i'll be back with sky news at 10
live here at buckingham palace but now
trevor phillips looks back at how
britain has changed during her majesty's
reign in the queen's people
[Music]
if our nation can be said to have a soul
her majesty for 70 years has been its
guardian angel
i'm trevor phillips i was born at the
dawn of the second elizabethan age
all these children would have grown up
with rationing
i've been rediscovering how we lived
sometimes there weren't enough coal to
make a fire so we have to just sit there
and shiver
and a little of how we loved
i went to get up and he went are you
going to give me a kiss then i went what
after you've had shellfish
i've been looking back at the good times
we all have proper pop out of fizzy
bottles which was possible
and the not so good times
i'd get pulled up two three times a
month and what's really sad about it
i thought it was normal
yet through it all one royal constant
at the same time a steadfast rock of
stability and a mirror of great change
in us
[Music]
queen elizabeth ii passes from the abbey
consecrated and dedicated to her life
work by the solemn and hallowed ritual
of coronation
a mantle almost a thousand years old is
laid on the shoulders of a new
generation
[Music]
the young queen will come to reign over
the largest empire the world had ever
seen
after a brittle war she had to symbolize
both a past and a future of prosperity
and peace
and so
this day of day's most memorable comes
to an end
and with it begins a new era the new
elizabethan h
long may she reign
in 1953 few would have pictured britain
as it is now jamaican right
after a decade of austerity my mother
agonized about how she'd tell my father
that they were about to have another
hungry mouth to
i'm going to try them and feed what
they're like
in the three score in 10 years since i
was born that young woman grew in
stature to become revered even perhaps
loved by her nation
of course she changed as did we her
people
but
like her majesty
whilst many things about us may have
looked different
an awful lot has remained the same
to try to disentangle the old from the
new i've been chatting to pals in
london's brixton for many emblematic of
how far we've come from the days when
the empire meant exotic lands across the
sea
[Music]
and i've been making some new friends in
berries and edmonds whose church spires
and niche municipal gardens recall a
britain that some thought was already
disappearing 70 years ago
but our journey starts in the former
manufacturing powerhouse of lancashire
where the paradox of continuity and
change is at its plainest so much
different yet so much the same
we've got a box of photographs of
coronation day on the 2nd june 1953
we've got
a parade here
so we've got um the young page boy
carrying the crown and then here comes
uh the queen
background
but it's kind of a classic northern
scene isn't it you've got the cobbled
streets the terrace terrace housing
and here's and here's the the coronation
of the of the queen
it's great she's sitting there on her
little throne and what do you think that
the queen would mean to a street like
this i think there's genuine enthusiasm
or strong feeling for this young queen
but i think it was also about marking
the end of something and a new
beginning
things are generally looking better
wages are higher there's full employment
there's a security of the nhs and the
welfare state they're not only marking
the coronation of the queen
the marking the beginnings of change
not just in their town but across the
country
[Music]
if you wanted a job there was always one
available
bolton stood at the heart of a global
industry that would fuel the new
elizabethan age
into the busy dark end of liverpool and
manchester come cargo's of raw cotton
from the far corners of the world
bolton's merchants grew rich turning the
empire's raw materials into cloth for
the growing population
[Music]
for two decades much of the country
shared its prosperity
of course it wasn't shared by everyone
most people went down the bus of course
because nobody had any cars
i'd get on the bus on saturday morning
get off in town walk through town to the
mercuto
and
we could buy
broughton biscuits then
for so much there's sixpence something
like that that were all we could afford
bolton's women could only dream of
buying the dresses made from the cloth
they wove but all the same they paid a
high price when i left school i worked
in mill
for two pounds ten a week
sweat and slave from mine till night to
keep me bobbing straight
i changed them with a gadget in case my
hands got burned
never stopping never stopping day and
night their turn
i pieced a thousand knots a week
to keep the yarn flowing
and at the end of every day tired feet
were homer going
i wrote that a long time ago
i started work when i was 15 in the
middle
and we had a long way to walk
from where i lived
we started it up at seven in the morning
and we had to be there on time or we got
our pair cut
and the pair wasn't as much as it was it
was only two pound
ten shillings
a week two shillings a week
and i had to give two pounds of that to
my mother and keep two shillings
so i could go out once a week that's all
it was so noisy
and very very busy
the machines were going all the time
that's why i'm a bit deaf i think
but you had to go whether you wanted or
not because it'd be a wage
but there was plenty of money in the
town
enough to erect and maintain public
buildings that rivaled anything down
south
bolton exuded self-confidence and civic
pride
bolton's art gallery opened in 1947
henry moore's sculptures were purchased
at that period of the 50s he was like
the big public figure in british art
barber heck with sculptures were
purchased and then works by the younger
generation like elizabeth frink
lynn chadwick robert clattworthy
so there's this decision i think that
bolton
would have this great collection of
contemporary art and would be a beacon
of culture across the northwest
what do you think that tells us about if
you like the mood of bolton and its own
self-image at the time
i think it shows great confidence in the
town that still this was a a textile
town
there was this sense that um bolton was
a powerful industrial town and that the
people of bolton should accept have
access to the greatest art being made at
that time but the town had its own
artists their canvas was made of grass
their frame the football field and their
gainsborough the great nat lofthouse
in coronation year lofthouse took the
wanderers to wembley to play in the fa
cup final and as ever what mattered to
the nation was signaled by a royal
presence the duke of edinburgh meets the
boys from blackpool at wembley before
their cup final battle with bolton
wanderers from the royal box her majesty
the queen watches the duke shake hands
with the white shirted wanderers who are
making their fourth appearance at
wembley i said some great players in the
50s
when i arrived eventually
a lot of the players were still talking
about that team
it would be as big as like man city it
may maybe at that time even man united i
mean
his supporters would be
turning out in the thousands and
thousands and
bolton get thousands smoothly castle
collects and passes the ball goes in
that loft house he shoots farm fumbles
and it's a goal
bolton have drawn first blood within 90
seconds
right from the opening whistle it looked
as though it was going to be bolton's
day but in the dying seconds the cup was
snatched from their graspers
[Music]
[Applause]
here come the winners gallant blackpool
who turned what seemed defeat into one
of the most dramatic victories ever seen
at wembley
although bolton gone to win the fa cup
later that decade
the stumble at wembley was perhaps an
omen of what was to come
within a generation the bustling town
would suffer a dramatic reversal of
fortune
one of the key trends in post-war
british history is
de-industrialization and the decline of
the manufacturing industries shifting
occupations i've been
looking at the kind of jobs that people
do now compared to the jobs that they
were doing in 1952 1953 there's an
extraordinary difference
and you know and that's changed
communities
it's changed places like bolton
so we were straight onto the front
street terrace and our house was
actually collapsing so it was showed up
with big pieces of wood and it was
collapsing into the old railway line
when it rained we took the curtains in
at the bottom because the rain came in
through the windows
so when you look at 1984
1990 even and a lot of people still
living like they were living in the
1950s shows the impact of how wages jobs
and the economic change was still
affecting people 30 years after the
mills started to close
berries and edmonds in the heart of east
anglia for many the very picture of
traditional england
this ancient market town with its
medieval churches and ruined abbeys
has been part of the royal story for
more than a thousand years
so this is liberty silks on linen
and it depicts the death of saint edmund
not very nice is it
definitely not it wouldn't want me
happen to you or me
the death of edmund is commemorated in
legend he was shot full of arrows after
being captured after losing a battle at
theftford he was tied to a tree
refused to renounce his christian faith
and then for good measure okay cut his
head off
he was buried at hoxton and it became a
place of pilgrimage and so much so they
moved him to the abbey here in boston
edmonds and became one of the biggest
abbeys in christendom
this town's story about itself
is inseparable from the story of the
sovereign
when the abbey itself was in existence
we had a lot of kings and queens
come to bearish and edmonds to pay
homage to edmund at the shrine
from um edward the first right the way
through to um obviously today with the
queen elizabeth we all we all love the
queen i think if you've served you
you've seen her you've appreciated her
you've seen what service she's given to
our nation
she came here for the maundy service
and she walked past us and handed out
morning money
and everyone was so proud that day the
streets were lined with people and they
all had special poses of flowers the
history and the legacy i think we all
like as well all that goes into all
these different services april the
annual st george's day parade brownies
cubs scouts guides on parade as they
have been for a hundred years
the day is supposed to be a homage to st
george but when these young people
pledge their allegiance there's just one
person who can claim their loyalty
and they really think of her as one of
them
tell me about what you
guys have been doing today and what it's
what it's about about what does it mean
i think representing the girls and the
girl guiding movement and we're really
honored to have had the queen as a
brownie a guide and then a ranger
herself so it's about showing our voices
and our representation i think she's an
icon for the british
the british identity and i think it's
about women being able to be icons for
themselves and for the communities that
they live in and grow in and work in
[Music]
what i love about this is that this is
the kind of england that my parents
would have recognized when they arrived
here seven decades ago just before the
start of the elizabethan
reign
the symbols that we're seeing here the
music the bands the flags were the same
symbols that were used all over the
empire
[Music]
this film taken on coronation day in
1953 bears a remarkable resemblance to
the event today
the parade musters in the same place
before marching through the town on the
same route
there were street parties going on i i
know that at the
top of the states there was a street
party carried out just outside the large
public house that used to be there
and i remember running after in a race
an orange that was bowled across the
road
and for that i got a queen's coronation
book
so that would have been your price for
winning the race which i've still got
somewhere
at home
but not everything remains the same at
the time of the coronation berry relied
on its fertile land to make a living
farming in east india is a highly
mechanized industry and by far the most
important source of live level
like the cotton mills of bolton
mechanization was transforming an entire
industry
but for the workers who remained as in
the mills the hours were long the wages
meager and the future uncertain
[Music]
the agricultural work is low paid
you know and agriculture is changing in
the post-war period partly this is
coming out of transformations to given
the reliance
um of the nation on agriculture during
the war but there's you know
mechanization and efficiency going on so
you know jobs in agriculture decline
very steeply
a great deal of the sugar used in the
british isles comes from east anglia
my father for most of his working life
he worked at the british sugar factory
for the manufacture and crushing of the
sugar beet
having food on the table was very
important
but there wasn't any luxuries as
such people who grew up in the early
20th century they never had the
facilities
they never had proper bathrooms they
never had toilet facilities you know
visiting the um
privy at the bottom of the garden you
know that sort of thing but certainly
after the second world war
and with rationing ending
people then started realizing there was
more to life they could enjoy
after feeding the nation the new reigns
first priority was obvious homes
the young queen and her dashing husband
a war veteran had their pick of palaces
but for their contemporaries new homes
had to be found in new places
britain was on the move
[Music]
it's fantastic to get a place well i
mean we never dreamed of getting around
house to be in london
i don't know what we would have done if
i had to come down here i don't know
where i would have gone or what where my
life would have gone to me it was
like absolutely fantastic i loved it and
you as well really because you'd lived
in all them flats where you'd have to
run up and down with your mum 50 years
on and not even a suffolk shower can
dampen dave and jean's certainty that
they made the right move
together since the early 60s they'd left
london's east end for berry at the end
of the decade
both found new jobs and more importantly
a new council house one of many which
had sprung up in and around the town
i just
moved into it quite easily it was
so easy going
um and plus the fact i had all my
friends from london come down with us we
adjusted very well yeah yeah we did just
very well yeah
and the fact is well i had my mum and
dad they moved as well and they were in
they lived in that row over there number
11. i mean they're not here now bless
them
what were your impressions of barry when
you got here as a place it was a slower
pace of life yes
a slower pace of life definitely and you
hadn't got you couldn't get on a bus and
go into the west end which when we were
caught and that was our weekend we was
always in the west end you know just get
on the bus or the tube but there's no
green and go up west you know so that's
slow wasn't it yeah it was a lot life
was a lot slower
the arrival of thousands of outsiders
like gene and dave
accelerated the transformation of berry
from a sleepy market town to the
affluent hub of today
[Music]
i think the biggest mover for bearish
edmonds was the london overspill coming
here
in the late 1950s 60s
up till that those periods bearish and
edmunds was reliant on agriculture
with the arrival of the london overspill
we also had the associated factories the
businesses etc we had large industrial
estates built to win in the
town that was a big change so gradually
people were starting to come to terms
with modern day living but it wasn't
just berry coming to terms with the
modern world it was the entire nation
across britain they were not just
building houses but whole new towns
motorways brought communities closer
together
and railway electrification slashed
travel times
every major city had new hospitals and
schools
but the economic boom demanded more
workers builders bus and train drivers
doctors nurses
and the new elizabethans had a ready
answer
in theory all the queen's people
belonged to one big happy imperial
family
in practice relations were strained from
the start
you know things wasn't nice at all what
we may do
for we can't go back home so we don't
have any money
you know i worked in a place and there
was this young white girl who told me to
my face that black people's brains were
small
like that
does the answer to these britishers
problems lie in britain or in the west
indies
and yet perhaps if we dig deep enough
we may find a solution hidden within the
conscience of us all
[Music]
few in the empire had ever seen royalty
in the flesh but radio had carried the
queen's voice to millions now air travel
brought her to many more
so we honor the queen because when i was
about
12 the queen came to jamaica
and we lined the streets and waved
[Music]
[Applause]
as the hugh foote the governor greeted
jamaica's sovereign the airfield became
tense with eagerness with wonder
the queen once said i have to be seen to
be believed
suddenly she was able to make believers
of entire nations
[Music]
well we grown up in the colonial days as
a child in jamaica
we celebrate empire day
and we all look forward to it
[Music]
loyalty combined with curiosity prompted
many to take up the challenge of
rebuilding the mother country
after all what was england except
another sister island under the same
monarch and the same flag
my dad said why does this child want to
leave us
and my mom said you know she's no longer
a child you know you have to let her go
in 1954 about 10 000 west indians came
to britain a few knew what to expect but
most of the women coming off boats in
their hats and gloves and a-line skirts
expected to set foot in the stylish
royal england that they'd seen in the
newsreels
in jamaica they didn't show us snow and
things and soot you know when i came
here i said this place what what is this
place
the snow was like this
and you could see all the smoke in the
skies because people were just burning
coal fire
i was surprised because you hear so much
of england the streets are paved with
gold basically but you know when you
come and you see the houses they weren't
what i expected to see
it's a big change we didn't have no
felicity no convenience
one room even when i was my first child
i was in one room the market in brixton
is for them a happier place than a
market in the tourist paradise they have
left many of the first arrivals from the
west indies settled here in south london
over the following decades they will be
joined by others from all over the
commonwealth
many of whom found work in what is now
held to be the greatest achievement of
the elizabethan age
the first job i had was in a laundry
and the second job was with a nhs in a
maternity hospital in barnet
when i spent 12 years in that job
so my
first wages in sensible hospital was
2.50 a week
i lived in
the nurse's home
in south london
we just stepped across to the hospitals
to look after our patients and yes it
was a very
good experience
that said it took a while for the
newcomers to grasp that some of her
majesty's subjects were a little less
equal than others
and that here whatever the bible said
not all god's children were welcome
we were the only two black people in the
church
and they didn't take us off for
communion
and after church
everybody rebica would come and greet
everybody and merry christmas and things
and he just looked at us and passed by
the vicar
and my my my cousin started to cry so i
said forget it
let's go home i was the stronger one
even though i was a sick one
and when we went home my one and said to
me millie she says how did you like it
and i told her she said well
i wouldn't tell you it's best for you to
go and see for yourself
something new and ugly raises its head
in britain in notting hill gate only a
mile or two from london's west end
racial violence
an angry crowd of youth chases a negro
into a green grocer shop while police
reinforcements are called up to check
the riot one of many that have broken
out here in a few days
[Music]
the archaic language can't hide the fact
that this was a country ill at ease with
itself
what should have been a new beginning
was starting to look like the end of an
era
what men saw at notting hill and the
kind of hostility that ruby experienced
at this church behind me were perhaps
early signs that the new queen far from
presiding over a second golden age
was in fact in for a bumpy ride
and it soon became clear that instead of
ushering in a new britain
she was actually seeing the collapse of
the old one her majesty queen
elizabeth's silver jubilee
25 eventful and glorious years
by the time of the silver jubilee in
1977
the crowd still turned out but the
national mood was darker a majesty fires
the fuse which will set a light the
first of a chain of jubilee beacons
the optimism of those first years was
replaced by strikes factory closures and
widespread job losses
the catastrophism preached by some both
left and right made many wonder whether
the glue that had kept a desperate
nation together would hold much longer
racial tension on britain's streets was
just one sign of the times
and for many it had a powerful impact
by the time i hit secondary school enoch
has made the rivers of blood speech
totally polarized the playground and all
of a sudden you know go back home this
is my home
and
it not only polarized the playground it
polarized the whole landscape man
don letts rockstar dj longtime pal and
rebel filmmaker he first made his name
telling the story of the alienated
children of the windrush generation
no this ain't kingston jamaica this is
london in the late 70s brixton to be
precise
yes the sun was shining but the people
were feeling the pressure all the same
black and white
the social climate with mass
unemployment political turmoil the rise
of the national front and to top it off
constant grief from the police
i think what's really odd about that
stuff it's when i was growing up
13 14 15 it was normal i kind of
expected it you know if i was going to a
movie i'd always build in an extra half
an hour because i'd not get pulled up on
the way to the movie and there was times
you know i developed kind of tactics to
deal with the police like you'd be
driving along and they'd be tailing you
from behind i'd stop my car get out of
my car walk up to him like officer can i
help you
totally throw in the best english i can
speak english better than these guys
across town in another britain crowds
were still flocking to that famous
palace and its familiar balcony
the pageantry of monarchy survived but
seemed increasingly detached from much
of the nation
[Applause]
don letts became the chronicler of the
challenge to tradition
for a moment anarchy found its voice
[Music]
the sex pistols insistence that there
was no future in england's dreaming
caught the imagination
punk rock was a minority taste the
radical spirit of the times infected
even the nerdiest of young people
[Music]
anti-racism swept me into politics it
was probably the one thing most people
could agree about and amazingly we found
an ally in an institution that most
young people thought was on its way out
when i was a student here britain seemed
that it's most angry and confrontational
and i guess i did my bit to fan the
flames as president of the student union
i organized sit-ins and demonstrations
pretty much non-stop for a year
but ironically
we i suppose you could call us the
coronation generation
found ourselves hand in hand with the
royal family on at least one thing
that britain didn't have to be a nation
divided by race
[Music]
in brixton a generation had arrived
thinking that they were already part of
a nation under one sovereign
their children grew up believing that
that nation had rejected them
one institution had the power to
reassure and to bridge the divide
and it's a responsibility embraced by
those who will wear the crown in times
to come
june 22nd the second in line to the
throne comes to brixton to mark windrush
day
the windrush voyagers came to rebuild
britain alongside his grandmother's
generation
one day their descendants will work
alongside william and
kate they're getting to know us like
asking us about what we're doing like
what we're interested in and yeah i
think that's why it was like already
outside
it makes us feel like who these guys
aren't just those people that are
they're disconnected
we felt connected
william carried a message from her
majesty that drew a line from the past
to the future
[Music]
alongside celebrating the diverse fabric
of our families our communities and our
society as a whole
something the win rush generation has
contributed so much to
it is also important to acknowledge the
ways in which the future they sought and
deserved has yet to come to pass
we are reminded of our shared history
and the enormous contribution of the
windrush generation
without you all britain would simply not
be what it is today
[Applause]
at the time of the coronation the future
of bolton as an industrial powerhouse
seemed secure
and a whole generation of youngsters was
destined for a career in cotton
inside the modern mill a great
is taking place
a progressive industry needs progressive
workers it needs trained technicians
but the brave new world was short-lived
and within a generation
cotton was dead on its feet
you could see the hive of industry from
the hills
a pile of smoking choking smoke hung
around
buying from abroad then came around
imported goods became the fashion and
killed the life and soul of every cotton
tone
we were about 22 though
bolton dot
spent all her working life in the mills
she now lives comfortably with her
daughter carol
but for much of their earlier lives when
the industry collapsed both mother and
daughter suffered extreme poverty
i grew up in 1984 we didn't even have an
indoor toilet we had to go through the
snow to get to the toilet and we're not
going back to the 1950s that my mum knew
of and this is 1984 when i was 16
and a lot of people live like that
like millions of working class women
carol was destined for a series of
dead-end jobs and domestic drudgery
until one day all that changed
i was about
21 and thought my life was over other
than having babies that's my dad said i
should have
and then someone suggested
well why don't you look at university
the cotton mills may have closed but the
old bolton technical college has adapted
over the years
at the beginning of the period we're
talking about the percentage of the
british population who went to
university was tiny and now it's
something that you know a lot of people
now think yes that's something i can do
that opportunity has really opened up
for people over the last kind of 78
years
carol was one of those who took the
opportunity and after four years she
graduated with a degree in education
i was now a teacher and i can't explain
it's like a woman who wants to have a
child and eventually gets pregnant when
you have a burning ambition inside you
and then you suddenly fulfill it at 26.
that's what baltimore university did for
me it provided me with my future career
today the university has more than 11
000 students two-thirds of whom come
from bolton and the north west
it plays a crucial role in training the
next generation of nurses and paramedics
for one of the country's great post-war
success stories the national health
service
get them across
you guys
what's happening there come on we employ
a nearly 6 000 staff in the nhs
they live in bolton their families live
in bolton healthcare is one of the only
growing industries really at the moment
right so the person is not responding
okay has he got a pulse
we work with the university to make sure
that we can have qualifications and
training places in this hospital
all right okay so i've got a pose
i'm going to check the circulation
and that's the way that we'll keep our
hospital fresh and alive and serving
this community you've done really well
when the patients on this ward were born
the single biggest employer here was the
cotton industry
no one could have foreseen a world in
which medicine would replace the mill as
a lifeblood of an entire community
the queen's crimson robe is removed
in the 70 years since the coronation the
scale of change in bolton has been
unimaginable but in all that time
enthusiasm for the queen remained
undiminished
i think she's brilliant
i think
it must be hard work doing what she's
done
the archbishop anoints her with holy oil
and consecrates her to her great office
i'm very proud of her yes i think she's
i think she's a good lady
she receives the orb
symbol of the dominion of the cross over
the world i think the royal family are
really important but the queen by far is
is the most important person to our
country
change over time is of course inevitable
but in the rural heartlands of england
where the roots of community stretch
back long before the industrial
revolution the pace of that change has
been just a little bit slower
a visitor from the berrisson edmonds of
the 1950s
would instantly recognize this place
with its quiet affluence its neat
churches its ethos of military service
there are many more people here now
there's a lot more hustle and bustle
but this town in essence remains a
microcosm of the nation that queen
elizabeth pledged to serve
all those many years ago
and the one thing that certainly hasn't
changed in berry is a shared sense of
history
a tradition of royal service and
devotion that has stretched back for
centuries
for our first prayer i'm going to invite
you all to put your hands together like
you'd see a picture of somebody praying
traditionally
it is a love that is modeled for us
by the queen
the queen who is in her own way a giant
of faith
who acts with integrity
care
and respect for those around her
[Music]
i mean she is our history and we've held
on to that
i think she's done an absolute marvelous
job
considering all the pressure she's been
under
i mean she couldn't walk away from it
could she
no there was no way out for it she
that's that was her life
and as she said right to begin i will
give everything to being a queen
and yeah i think she's done a great job
most of britain has only ever known one
monarch
we had no choice like her we were born
to it
but over a tumultuous seven decades even
those who dislike the institution have
come to celebrate even to love the
person
men and women of the windrush generation
did have a choice most expected to
return to the caribbean one day
and there were many who would gladly
have waved them off our shores but they
stayed
love it now because i don't know any
other life
because
i came here quite young
so i adapt myself
to the culture
of this country
i just take what i get and enjoy
i go back for holiday but my home is
still in england
[Music]
i'm glad that i came here
and this country been very very very
good to me
and i love this country and i'm not
going home and i'm not going nowhere
else
[Applause]
pretty much everybody here came to this
country from somewhere else and most
have lived through the entire
elizabethan reign
[Music]
for many this country didn't turn out to
be the place they expected
and not in a good way
but what is really striking is that
nobody have talked to regrets coming and
staying and most telling of all
when they talk about home
they're not talking about the old
country they're talking about brixton
across the span of one remarkable
lifetime this country has been
transformed
the lesson of those seven decades well
for me
that a nation secure in the symbols of
continuity need to have no fear of
change in the reality
maybe the magic of this age of elizabeth
is not the past that she preserved
but the future that she has secured
and that is cause for praise
thanksgiving
and celebration
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
that is
[Music]
welcome back to buckingham palace where
tonight we've learned details of how the
nation will mourn queen elizabeth over
the next few days
this afternoon king charles met senior
political figures after a special
ceremony earlier at st james's palace
which officially proclaimed him king
and in windsor the new prince and
princess of wales greeted well-wishers
along with the duke and duchess of
sussex
in something of a surprise appearance
princess william and harry and their
wives kate and megan met crowds and
collected floral tributes and spoke to
some of those who'd gathered to pay
their respects
earlier in a short statement on
instagram prince william paid tribute to
his grandmother saying it will be some
time before the reality of life without
granny will truly feel real
well all through today and into the
evening people have continued to come
here to buckingham palace to pay their
respects
melinda veselnovic has been speaking to
some of them
it's got even busier here within the
last hour or so you can see this area
here has really become a focal point for
people to come together take a moment to
reflect
and think about what the queen
meant to them and we can now speak to
one of the families that were here today
the samu family who have come together
to really share in the collective
feeling and grief over the queen's death
tell me why why did you guys feel that
you wanted to come here today
just to pay our respects because she was
a very humble
she was nice she was
kind
caring she was a nice queen all together
um
even though we never got to meet her she
would what she did for everyone around
the world was very nice and what did the
queen mean to you
i mean she meant a lot to me but she was
so like down to earth
whatever she did she thought about the
country first like doing that for 70
years non-stop is a lot and she just
meant
like a lot a huge amount to me and
you've come down here as well with your
family the queen has been the constant
throughout your life you're very young
how do you feel now at the prospect of
her being gone
um
it is a bit well it's quite shocking
really because we were born into this
world into this country when she was she
was on top really we've known only her
as the queen like ruling morning and now
now she's gone it is quite it's quite
you feel it really quite a lot
and finally mom and dad why did you feel
compelled to come here today
with your family
yeah um when your news broke all the
children in the house they were crying
and it was on my birthday as well and
they were all crying tears the whole
house and as a veteran of the british
army i swore allegiance to the queen as
well so it means so much to us and we we
follow the royal family we are
we are very very very much part of the
royal family and part of everything that
the establishment stands for so it's
personal to us and we just want to come
here to pay our respect to
ask god to send our angels to you know
take her into heaven and be in a very
happy place and finally the fact that
you're here with other people sharing in
your emotion does that bring any comfort
to you
oh yeah definitely um we feel much
better that we're here even though we we
cannot see any of the royal family
members but we are happy that we can
make it and also we're looking forward
to come for the funeral
yeah
thank you very much for talking to sky
news so really a lot of outpouring of
emotions still here people coming laying
flowers laying tributes and the weight
of history really felt here by
buckingham palace now
well that's milena a little earlier on
but believe it or not the crowds are
still here and people are still coming
as we speak
now the queen was revered around the
world but she always had a special place
in her heart for the commonwealth which
she saw grow from just a few former
colonies to a club of 56 nations some of
which were never part of the british
empire and many people from those
countries including my own family made
the uk their home during her reign lisa
holland has been speaking to
commonwealth communities
we all call you grandma yes
in south london friends and family call
louise the queen of brixton
not just because she's a great great
grandmother who fostered more than 20
children but at 96 years of age she was
born on exactly the same day as queen
elizabeth ii
they call you the queen of brixton i
hear yes yes yes well
i had birthday
comes up at that time i said
he's the queen birthday and for me too
i feel good
louise came to britain as part of the
windrush generation i shall strive to
follow
the inspiring example
i have been set but as she watched the
proclamation of a new king she recalled
the late queen visiting jamaica in the
1950s the waves talk
to everyone and we've revealed back
in multicultural brixton scratch the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the queen's decades of
global commonwealth tours
when i was at school when i remember the
helicopter land
at the back of the school i'm sierra
from that no it's not the time for
morning
now is the time to celebrate
the lady life she'll live our life to
the max she's always made everyone feel
like
part of the commonwealth part of
britain you know so i just think like
the world's a poorer place without her
what's also clear is just how
significant the queen's global influence
and standing was in so many countries
around the world
there's no
queen anywhere else like only united
kingdom
in this fabric shop we met bill al who
said it was watching the queen from a
young age which inspired him to want to
move to the uk from india nearly 20
years ago you always heard about the
news like queen sometimes picture come
in on the newspaper what's it like
michael who grew up in ghana says the
queen's legacy will live on she's a very
strong brand now we've got a king she
might probably follow the same footsteps
that the mom left behind
britain's new king already has the
goodwill of those who revered his mother
to help build his own future as monarch
lisa holland sky news south london
well as well as being queen of the
united kingdom elizabeth ii was of
course queen of the commonwealth despite
a growing republican movement in
australia her death has overwhelmingly
been met with sorrow
cordelia lynch reports from sydney on
australia's response
[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the queen once walked her son must
now follow and here in australia it is a
turning point we just loved her we just
loved it the older we got
the more we could relate to her because
she felt like she was just always there
for us i'm just like a lot of other
older australians we're just grieving
because
she was the queen of australia a lot of
people that's lost on a lot of people it
felt like the queen was almost um
immortal at some point you know she uh
she's lived a long time and
yeah i mean even
though she
was quite old when she passed it still
came as a shock
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit these shores
[Music]
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population spellbound
i want to tell you all
how happy i am to be amongst you
and how much i look forward
to my journey through australia
such outbursts of spontaneous affection
she loves this country she loved this
country i should say
she'd been here 16 times and you don't
do that if you don't like the place and
she came back again and again and again
and she found the same thing again and
again again warmth affection
i think she really admired the
resilience of australians
who work and live off the land here
it's very nice to see you in person this
time yes your majesty
scott morrison admired her ability to
make light work of calming his nerves
she had he says a regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see her like again but
we won't
where do you see that relationship
with the crown going there does remain a
strong connection and an appreciation
i mean our success in australia is in no
small part
due to the stability of our democracy of
our constitutional system and the crown
sits at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic
and that conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that
feels strikingly rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen that appears enduring
cordelia lynch sky news sydney australia
well let's take you through now what we
know about how the next week will unfold
the state funeral for the queen will be
held on monday the 19th of september at
11 a.m at westminster abbey
but ahead of the funeral tomorrow sunday
the 11th the queen's coffin will leave
balmoral for hollywood palace at 10 a.m
further proclamations will be read in
the scotland wales and northern ireland
devolved parliaments
on monday the 12th of september the king
will deliver a speech at westminster
hall
before he travels to edinburgh
the queen's coffin will be taken to
saint john's cathedral the procession
leaves hollywood at 2 35 p.m and a
service takes place at the cathedral at
3 p.m
on tuesday the 13th the queen's coffin
will be flown to london to rest at
buckingham palace in the throne room
where it will be dressed with a crown
orb and scepter
the king will travel to northern ireland
on wednesday the 14th of september the
queen's coffin will be taken in
procession from buckingham palace to the
palace of westminster
the coffin is then moved to westminster
hall for lying in state
lying in state will last four full days
on friday the 16th the king will travel
to wales
on monday the 19th
the state funeral takes
place over the course of her reign the
queen became perhaps the most
photographed person ever to have lived
and her image used in everything from
pop art to punk
katie spencer has been looking at the
life of a cultural icon
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous her
image at the core of british culture
the queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premier of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she'd play in maintaining
the allure of brand britain
i remember when i was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
prince philip who was about the best
looking man
in the world i mean everybody at school
had a crush on him and i kept scrapbooks
of the queen everything that was in the
papers or the magazines i cut out and it
was um princess elizabeth's wedding and
she was a fairy tale princess she really
was she was gorgeous she had a hand span
waist big wonderful eyes we all just
loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her platinum jubilee
um
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich i
always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the relentless public
infatuation with this woman
if you imagine i'm going to drop
everything and come down to london
before i attend to my grandchildren
who've just lost their mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
lucy and freud to andy warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her legacy
i remember when i was first commissioned
it was a daunting prospect you know the
queen the most portrayed woman in
history i asked if man would like to
rest in between shots
that'd be fine just i was conscious of
all the light onto her so
she closed her eyes and
that was the moment it was you know
it didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at sitting for artists was part
of her cultural duty but she also
inspired some significant unofficial art
an anti-establishment target epitomized
on the cover of the 1977 sex pistols
single had a faced likeness and easy act
of rebellion
if you went to most west indians home at
the time they would probably have a
picture of the queen on a wall as well
as a picture of jesus
while rock photographer dennis morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the queen's
silver jubilee he was following the
pistol's provocative boat trip on the
thames
at that time um the monarchy was very
very strong we were
not particularly liked for being
anti-monarchy in that sense as i grew
older and knew more and more about it i
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot
to hold something like that together in
the way she has over the years so you
know for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many british artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
arts for those who embraced her
magisterial authority or rebelled
against it she inspired her influence
over british culture irrefutable and
unique
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
katy spencer sky news
well tonight here at uh buckingham
palace as you can see people continue to
arrive the crowds are continuing and
probably will still be coming
well into the night on the day that king
charles iii exceeded to the throne that
is all
for this hour from me
i'll be back with sky news at 10 coming
up next
trevor phillips is here with a royal
special program
good evening from buckingham palace
i'm trevor phillips and welcome to a sky
news royal special on the death of the
queen
coming up in the next hour
the making of a monarch king charles is
confirmed at an ancient ceremony the
accession council televised for the very
first time
in carrying out the heavy task that has
been laid upon
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray for the guidance and help
of almighty god
looking on some of the most senior
figures in the country
including every living prime minister
[Music]
gun salutes rang out across the united
kingdom in honor of the new king
buckingham palace confirms that the
queen's state funeral will be held on
monday september the 19th with the day
declared a bank holiday
[Music]
a united front
the prince of wales pays tribute to his
grandmother and makes a surprise
appearance in windsor alongside princess
catherine
prince harry
and megan
[Music]
and from pop art to punk
we'll look at how the queen became a
cultural icon
[Music]
good evening from buckingham palace and
welcome to this special program on the
death of the queen
it would be easy to underestimate what
has taken place today
it used to be said by courtiers that
showing the inner workings of the
monarchy would be unwise letting the
daylight in on the magic might destroy
the mystique
well the new king is already testing
that belief to the utmost today started
with live tv coverage of a ceremony
never previously seen by the outside
world
it ended with a king his queen consort
the prince and princess of wales and the
duke and duchess of sussex on royal
walkabout
pressing the flesh
literally embracing their people on the
streets of windsor and here outside
buckingham palace
there's never been a day like it
this perhaps is a sign of what is to
come
with our first report our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills has more on
the proclamation of the king
it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual that was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start
and now the end of the second
elizabethan age
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
as politicians past and present of all
political persuasions including every
former living prime minister gathered
inside st james's palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy counsellors
to acknowledge formally the change of
reign
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
and of his other realms and territories
king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith
god save the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by king charles
his heir and queen consort close by
as we were all able to witness a moment
never seen before
a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting
personally declaring his intention to
serve
my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you
the entire nation
and i think i may say the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we have all
suffered
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks
for this most faithful life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
and in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray
for the guidance and help
of almighty god
it's the personal touches his family
around him the inkwell on the table
given him as a gift by prince william
and prince harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives of the commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much her majesty the
queen had given us but also
welcoming the new king
and for the new king charles to make
those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way i think was moving for
everyone
and it is a moment i'm sure no one in
that room will ever forget
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
echoed in the city of london as the
second proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal exchange
god save the king
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the united kingdom
for now buckingham palace remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the mall
but behind them a king who wants to be
seen who wants us to understand what
we're now witnessing as like us he's
quickly had to adjust rhiannon mills sky
news at st james's palace
joining me throughout this hour is lord
woolley uh simon to his friends
principal of hamilton college cambridge
simon you've just come from uh palace of
westminster where uh the
mps and members of the lords have been
sharing their memories
of her majesty
what is the atmosphere in there like it
was an incredible time to be in that
that space that many lords and ladies
paying tribute to to her majesty the
queen and at the end we took an oath to
the new king
speech after speech was lay and bear
the the selfless public duty that this
this queen this role model this
figurehead has shown not just here in
the in the uk but across the world
so it's been an extraordinary day
you spoke yourself to tonight i did i
did i mean do you have to say well i had
to say about my experience uh right
across the road there at uh at
buckingham palace uh three years ago
actually
today or almost today when i was
knighted
and knighted by a match to the queen and
i i took my son there and i was as
nervous as hell i mean who wouldn't be
right on such a big occasion but she
lent into me she made me feel
comfortable we started chatting and in
the end joking and uh when i came back
to my son my son leaned into me he said
dad dad you made the queen laugh what
did you say
and i said i can't tell you son it's a
secret yeah i was just gonna i was just
gonna ask you there you said this joke
but i know you can't but very speechless
many speeches you know personal uh
general
extremely moving
and a lot of a lot of the peers
we're talking about that we need to i
guess take a leaf out of her majesty's
book
when it comes to selfless public duty
the public service is sacrifice she said
in that documentary i think one of the
interesting things that we've seen the
last 48 hours has been both from the
royal family itself particularly the
king
but also from those who knew the queen
that the experience has been very
personal people have
given tributes that mrs may
told a joke anecdotes
by the million um
do you think this is a sign of a sort of
closeness perhaps to the royal family
that
people didn't quite expect well it's
great to see i mean when i walked down i
saw families with their kids i saw one
one parent sent to the child you know
the queen was when she died and the
child said 90 96 how many years did she
reign she said 17 she was six years of
age you know this is a nation coming
together in in sorrow
in grief but actually united
united to united to say
this was our great monarch
and what it means to be british what it
means to be part of the commonwealth i'm
really pleased i'm really pleased that
the nation has come together in this way
not only to celebrate the life of a
great human being
but also to celebrate the incoming of
our new king a good man
who i think will reign in in a similar
uh i guess inclusive way as the queen
did well that's an interesting point
because actually um
what we've seen today
starting with the accession council
televised for the first time so that
people
the people who've never seen this before
had it right there live and the walk
about this afternoon do you think this
is uh
the development of a style of course the
queen was the first to do the walkabout
back in 1970 i think um but are we
seeing
a development of that openness well i
think so i mean look the king would do
things his way
and i've been lucky enough to to work
with him to collaborate with him and
i've seen what a what a human being he
is he's very personable he likes to
listen he likes he likes to be tactile
and and i think that if he can
govern in that way as head of state
and people warm to it that i think
people will get another view
a more fuller view
of our king than often you read in the
newspapers
do you think just very briefly that um
the
new prince of wales will essentially be
taking up some of uh his duties i do
hope so i mean look i've been involved
in in some of the the bodies that is
that the prince was
now king that the princess trust was
involved with and they are super
important for example the prince's trust
has helped over 2 million young young
men and women often from black asian
minority ethnic communities it's so
important it's a pathway for them to
develop i i hope that prince william
takes that baton and runs with it simon
thank you very much for the moment okay
uh we've talked uh a bit already about
the different tone today uh we know and
we've seen from uh some of the coverage
of the last couple of days that the
queen with the first tv documentary uh
prince philip the first royal to be
interviewed on television and of course
the invention of the royal walkabout has
did something extraordinary to bring the
mystery of the monarchy
down to the ground down to the people
and
she it is estimated that about a third
of the british people have actually seen
or met her so
perhaps what we've seen today is the
development of that uh but to
talk a little bit more about what we've
seen i'm going to turn now to our
correspondent laura bundock laura
new style today i think so i mean the
day started
as perhaps you might have expected this
very ceremonial event this ancient this
arcane this traditional thing none of us
has seen before mostly because it's
never been televised before but in some
ways very inaccessible as well
and then of course after that formality
you have
the absolute accessibility of everything
so we saw the new king
make his way from the palace along the
mouth stopping to then go out and greet
people in person and then perhaps of all
an even bigger surprise a walkabout in
windsor not just the new prince and
princess of wales but a royal source
said at their request the sussexes as
well so you see
for the first time since 2020 for years
now
two royal brothers brought together and
the late queen always spoke about her
soft power and i think perhaps
here it is we see princess william
princess prince harry we know of their
rift it's been playing out so publicly
and yet the four of them them and their
their wives case and megan walking in
windsor to go and meet the crowds it was
quite a moment
is it the healing of that relationship
we don't know but it certainly was an
incredible moment and again having had
the huge ceremony at the beginning of
the day
this is the other side to the royal
family i think the new king very keen to
present you know his replacement as
prince of wales the new princess of
wales and the two brothers
as well a site perhaps we had not
expected to see i i thought it was very
striking the shot of the four of them
walking out of the gates at windsor
going to inspect the flowers and i was
thinking
we know that
that what
nobody knows exactly what's happened
behind closed doors but we know that
these two operations have for quite a
long time been uh working separately and
it did strike me that um
her majesty had a rather uh particular
capability of rather softly exercising
steel and i just wondered whether her
son
what we saw today was her son's first
exercise as king in essentially saying i
really am not bothered
what goes on between you but you have a
responsibility to the country get out
there
we will never know what is said behind
closed palace doors but what we do know
is certainly when the sussexes arrived
in england there was no expectation they
would meet any member of the royal
family but clearly the events of this
week have changed all that to the extent
they have changed that we don't know but
you would like to think perhaps that the
new king as he tries to present himself
as the future he tries to show the
continuity of the monarchy that he will
make it a meaningful role that he will
speak to the people that he will
understand their needs as he begins this
new reign is trying to involve his
family as much as possible how much of
the family will be involved as we know
the sussexes have no official royal role
we don't know yet but certainly the
pictures i think are historic images
from the pageantry at the start of the
day to this relaxed moment and the
bringing together of two brothers we did
not expect to see side by side in this
way and perhaps that was um
the signal that he gave in his address
yesterday when he said
in
really i think affectionate terms that
you
could see the father in him
that
he expresses love for harry and megan
and i wonder if that might have been the
opening to say
you may not do the official you may not
be part of the firm but you can
certainly play a role
in uh what we do as a country well it
was a pivotal speech yesterday it was
obviously the tribute to his late mother
but it was very much him setting out
giving us a glance a glimpse into what
his monarchy will look like the kind of
monarch he will be he referenced with
those fitting and very touching words to
the queen consort to camilla to the
prince and you prince and princess of
wales but he didn't leave out megan and
harry and you do wonder did that have
anything to do with the the olive branch
request that the prince of wales made to
his brother to join him today in windsor
thank you laura well buckingham palace
have released details of key moments in
the coming days
the state funeral for the queen will be
held on monday the 19th of september at
11 am at westminster abbey
tomorrow sunday 11th the queen's coffin
will leave balmoral for hollywood palace
at 10 a.m
further proclamation will be read in
scotland wales and northern ireland
devolved parliament
on monday the 12th of september the king
will deliver a speech at westminster
hall
before he travels to edinburgh the
queen's coffin will be taken to sinjal's
cathedral
the procession leaves hollyrood at 2 35
p.m
and the service takes place at the
cathedral at 3 pm
the king will travel to northern ireland
on tuesday the 13th the queen's coffin
will be flown to london to rest at
buckingham palace in the throne room
where it will be dressed with a crown
orb and scepter
on wednesday the 14th of september the
queen's coffin will be taken in
procession from buckingham palace to the
palace of westminster
the coven is then moved to westminster
hall for lying in state and lying in
state will last four full days
on friday the 16th the king will travel
to wales
and on monday the 19th the state funeral
takes place and laura uh is still with
me laura is this much as expected
i think so i mean
there is there is no doubt that the
queen herself would have had a big part
in the planning of all this we know the
planning has has been taking place for
many many years now but we're getting
the details now so we know the exact
movements both of her coffin and also of
the king himself too as he wants to move
around the rest
of the united kingdom to visit all the
different nations and so starting in
scotland then moving to northern ireland
and wales on friday very much carrying
on with the official duties but as much
as possible meeting people who he knows
are sharing his grief who are mourning
with him as well but i think a lot of
eyes will now be on the moment from
wednesday when the queen's coffin will
be lying in state and members of the
public i'm sure many of the people here
will be allowed the chance to file past
her coffin and pay in person their
respects and if you judge the cues from
her late father's funeral when he was
lying in state the cues were enormous
the same for the queen mother as well
and i'm you would expect the cues will
stretch back i think it will be
remarkable scenes and then of course a
funeral perhaps the like of which we've
never seen before on monday not just the
dignitaries and that but the number of
people i think who will want to be there
in some way
to watch the final farewell to the late
queen i think it'll be it'll be a
remarkable event won't it i mean i think
the queen
uh mother had uh something like 300 000
people who filed past her um
coffin and uh i expect we will see
a number possibly a multiple of that for
the queen they're not just here but
around the world you know we have the
internet now and the numbers will be
millions and millions from here to every
part of the world i imagine wanting to
watch and witness what is a moment in
history
laura thank you very much
indeed wrexham in north wales was due to
be celebrating its recent award of city
status as part of the queen's platinum
jubilee celebrations earlier this year
instead tonight its residents are coming
to terms with the death of the monarch
and the beginning of a new era of royal
rule
katarina vitozi has been looking at how
one community has been dealing with a
new royal reality
[Music]
today in wrexham as church bells rang
out to mark king charles's accession
inside a model of the late queen's crown
came down
there was meant to be a party here today
to mark wrexham getting city status
celebrations now obviously postponed
the late queen granted city status and
this was the day when we were going to
have the uh formal official celebration
to mark that so we had a really big
service involved so
at this point on saturday morning we
were expecting the place to be sort of
full of people and full of bustle what's
the mood been like over the last few
days
it's just been a sort of yeah almost a
sense of unreality that we can't quite
take it in because she's been such a
constant for the whole of our lives
really
wrexham has a royal pedigree
even if history hasn't always been kind
to the place itself
at wrexham they started a tour of a
thoroughly depressed area where the old
heavy industries have failed and a
desperate attempt is being made to
attract new companies specifically in
light industry
things have been changing pretty fast
here in wrexham the town becoming a city
its football team getting taken over by
hollywood actor ryan reynolds and now
wrexham and indeed the whole of wales
has got a new prince and princess
alison williams met princess diana here
in 1991 and now welcomes her son prince
william and his wife taking on the role
i think william and kate are amazing
i think they will make a brilliant
prince princess of wales it's nice that
they lived here for so long
it means that they're interested and
they understand
more about wales
the new prince and princess of wales
also bring with them this
a way of operating online that's as
slick as in real life
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck tonight
but in a moment where the monarchy is
looking to its future for some even
these social media savvy younger royals
feel somewhat distant
on their instagram they post all these
pretty things they're starting we don't
get to see that it would be impossible
for them to feel relatable to anyone in
our generation at the very least anyway
because of the struggles we're having
with the inflation and like living
crisis you know they don't have to deal
with that as much as our slot that's
what we all want as a country we want
them to bring
the uk into the new generation and be
more relatable he's got a look back to
his grandfather and his father's
footsteps for instance she got the duke
of edinburgh award and then the prince's
trust award
in the moment the queen died royal roles
shifted titles changed but the
responsibility remains to engage the
public and preserve a legacy
category of toxicity sky news in wrexham
the queen was revered around the world
but she always had a special place in
her heart a soft spot for the
commonwealth which she saw grow from
just a few former colonies to a club of
56 nations some of which were never part
of the british empire and many people
from those countries including my own
family
made the uk their home during her reign
sky's lisa holland has been speaking to
commonwealth communities
we all call you grandma yes
in south london friends and family call
louise the queen of brixton
not just because she's a great great
grandmother who fostered more than 20
children but at 96 years of age she was
born on exactly the same day as queen
elizabeth ii
they call you the queen of brixton i
hear yes yes
yes when
i had birthday
comes up at that time i said
he's the queen birthday and for me too
i'm feeling good
louise came to britain as part of the
windrush
generation i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set but as she watched the
proclamation of a new king she recalled
the late queen visiting jamaica in the
waved
1950s
to everyone and we've revealed back
in multicultural brixton scratch the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the queen's decades of
global commonwealth tours
when i was at school when i remember the
helicopter land
at the back of the school i'm sierra
from that um no it's not the time for
morning now is the time to celebrate
the lady life she'll live our life to
the marks she's always made everyone
feel like
part of the company well part of
brit you know so i just think like the
world's a poorer place without her
what's also clear is just how
significant the queen's global influence
and standing was in so many countries
around the world there is no
queen anywhere else like only united
kingdom
in this fabric shop we met bill al who
said it was watching the queen from a
young age which inspired him to want to
move to the uk from india nearly 20
years ago you always heard about the
news like queen sometime picture come in
on the newspaper what's it like
michael who grew up in ghana says the
queen's legacy will live on it's a very
strong brand now we've got a king she
might probably follow the same footsteps
that the mom left behind
britain's new king already has the good
will of those who revered his mother to
help build his own future as monarch
lisa holland sky news south london
it's a rather striking thing isn't it
simon that um
when you go i know you travel a lot uh
you go around the world when people talk
about the queen there's only one person
generally speaking that comes to mind
um
how do you think
we got to that place is it just her or
is it britain or our history i think i
think it's her i think it's her quiet
strength her humility and when going to
these countries from far and beyond i
think that she wants to know about them
she wants to know about the people and
so they remember
and and actually the same as with prince
charles i've just been in malaysia and
they were talking about his visit in in
2017 i think the thing is being present
and making every individual feel special
the queen has done it the queen did it
over 70 years and the prince over 50
years it's called duty and sacrifice and
they both know about him
the um
of course for
many countries the relationship with
britain has a complicated history um and
i know you were in barbados when the uh
when the king uh went to
the ceremony where they installed their
new head of state and so on now
it's a tricky thing and the queen seemed
to
seem to have managed it extraordinarily
well but do you think that
the new king is going to face some extra
strains because we hear talk about this
in australia we talk about it all over
the caribbean that
it's time for that relationship to
change well i think he showed leadership
with that i mean he said to the people
of barbados to mere motley the president
look this is your choice and the beauty
about it is when you have those adult
conversations you can make that choice
some will some won't but you can remain
in the commonwealth you can remain
part of the family do business share
culture it's not that i win you lose
it's that we reset in a modern world
with a modern britain and i thought he
was brave because i'm sure that there
were detractors waiting for him to slip
up but he didn't
and uh it's no surprise to me that this
morning the the bayesian prime minister
motley pay tribute
paid tribute to him with this views
about the climate change and which is
held for many decades but also his
vision for disadvantaged young people
and making sure that they have a pathway
trevor
i heard that and um i i thought that the
interesting thing was that uh in spite
of the fact that basically a few months
ago barbados said thank you very much
hadn't had enough we've got our own
ahead of state um it was a rather warm
tribute yeah do you think that the
vehicle which i think the queen
the late queen always thought of as the
future the commonwealth um is
right now going to be a priority for the
new king i think so because it binds us
all together and so you know we we reset
we change the historical legacy of the
enslavement of africans and uh
colonialism i mean you know that has to
be settled and this is part of that
process
what you get after that is up to us and
now we negotiate it but it has to be
inclusive it has to be respectful
i think they that king now is well
placed
not least because of the back story
you know he's been traveling around the
world he knows all these leaders he
knows their their histories and so i
think if we have adult conversations we
can get to we can get to a positive
place trevor what do you think um the
first thing he has to do to send a
signal i guess that
this is a new time
uh we are no longer if you like the in
charge of things but we want to be
friends and partners to be honest with
you i think he's been doing that
and and people and people who know him
and the countries they've been to will
also recognize that too
now how fast that moves and how it moves
is between is between the countries and
what their people want and then
negotiating them with with with the new
king
he above all
knows that our nation has to let go of
that of that old god
okay
lord wooly thank you very much indeed
let's reflect on today's events now with
margaret mcmillan uh the distinguished
emeritus professor of international
history at oxford university who joined
us now i think from toronto
uh good evening uh professor macmillan
um i i understand that canada
is already
um got out of the blocks and has
declared uh the new king king of canada
is that correct
it is i think and i mean it is but uh
canada has a strong relationship with
the monarchy um we see it i think as a
symbol of stability we still have a
governor general after all and there
seems to be very little will to change
that
do you think that um
the that relationship is uh stable for
the future uh many people will say that
uh in fact you know people have been
writing in newspapers today
that
we are
about to face a reckoning which has been
delayed by the personality and the
respect and admiration in which the late
queen was held but we're now going to
have to face a reality in which other
countries australia canada caribbean
countries some african countries uh want
to reset that relationship are you
getting any sign of that in canada
in canada there's no strong republican
movement occasionally we get a few
flurries i think we've been so focused
on our own internal constitutional
issues that we haven't really had time
to think about the monarchy all that
much and i think also a lot of canadians
like their monarchy as a symbol that
were not the united states and when you
live next door to a great big power
there's some you like to distinguish
yourselves in some way
i don't i think there's been a reset
anyway and there's always been a
discussion of the commonwealth of what
it should be i think that the death of
the queen and the accession of king
charles iii will
see that conversation continuing but i
don't expect it to be a decisive moment
and as lord wooly was saying different
countries will make their own decisions
about where they want to go with this
there is of course a a constitutional
issue uh always the governor general of
course is uh
the the the representative of the crown
in canada um there is always an issue
about
the powers and whether there is in uh
intervention or not uh do canadians do
you think really just see the monarch as
a symbol of a historical
link and as if you like a cultural uh
symbol that tells people as you say we
are not america
i think that's how canadians see is
there more to it than that
i don't think so the um you know since
since the second world war
governors general have been appointed on
the recommendation of the canadian
government so the british government has
not interfered at all and we now run our
own affairs we have been running our own
affairs for a great many years now i
think people here have seen the queen
actually very much as people in other
parts of the world including the united
states have seen the queen as someone
who exemplified good solid qualities i
mean the words that keep coming out
dignity um decisiveness doing her job um
not complaining these are the sorts of
things that have been said in the
american media that being said around
the world and so i think canadians share
that view is here as an admiral person
an icon if you like of the ways in which
we'd like to see heads of state behave
and someone who stood somehow above
party politics
and so i think for canadians the queen
was as important as a symbol of that
type of behavior and a symbol of those
values as she was of any relationship
with britain
can we talk a little bit more about if
you like the the broad role whether it's
cultural or constitutional of monarchy
um there is a point of view that says
that uh in
the 21st century
with the spread of democracy with the
practice of
liberal democracy the the maturity of
parliamentary democracies it is
in some way anachronistic
what do you think in countries like
united kingdom that canada
many of the commonwealth countries that
share a history what do you think that
the con continuing
practical
valuable role of
monarchy might be
monarchy in the as the way it's evolved
i think and i'm thinking of the british
monarchy in particular can represent
something that represents all the people
that stands above the political fray
that reminds us that we are part of one
community and i think that in itself is
valuable um in other types of
democracies in republics for example the
head of state is always a member of a
party always always has a political
position and sometimes that works very
well sometimes you get presidents in the
united states for example who are very
divisive who who divide up americans
against each other and i think i can't
imagine who you're referring to
professor macmillan oh i'm very careful
i'm very
careful look i can look southwards very
easily from where i am at the moment
but you know i think i think there is
something of value
in someone who says look i'm here for
all the people i i represent a sort of
continuity i don't have any power the
british monarch doesn't have
significant power as as the monarch once
used to have but does represent that
sort of continuity and represents the
hope that we can act actually on
occasion see ourselves as part of one
community
there's another um point of view about
this and i think it came up rather
recently in canada which is that uh of
course the relationship is one that is
bet that is embedded deeply in history
and not not all of that history is one
that every country wants to remember uh
in the caribbean uh part of that history
is slavery in uh
africa part of that uh history is
the worst part elements of colonialism
civil war uh violent struggles for
independence and in canada of course
there is the history perhaps of the
treatment of uh first nation people
how do you think that this monarch is
going to be able to deal with those
issues which i think perhaps are much
more prevalent much more present in the
public mind than they might have been
in her mother's time
it's important isn't it to to look at
our past in all its complexity and not
try and gloss over things that were done
and i think all i can say there is that
we have to confront things that were
done and sometimes those were done in
the name of the british crown sometimes
they were done by the locals not
necessarily in the name of the crown and
quite often um there was objection to
the ways in which the indigenous of
being treated for example in australia
and in canada from the british
authorities so i think we have to accept
the past and all its complexity we can't
gloss over what happened in the past but
i think we also have to accept that
individuals countries institutions
change and what we have to do is try and
deal with the deep scars that have been
left at the post and try and continue to
try and build communities that actually
work and i don't see the fact that the
crown or indeed many institutions in
britain and in canada were responsible
for the bad treatment of some of their
their fellow citizens or fellow subjects
should make us throw the whole lot out
um you know i tend to be
not a revolutionary on that i think
you're better trying to amend what you
have and improve it than than scrap
everything and start a game
uh finally if i may just ask you quickly
about what if you like a personal uh
issue for uh
canada
your prime minister mr trudeau um
seemed very emotional when he responded
uh on thursday i think it was to
the
death of uh her majesty the queen and of
course she had known his father as prime
minister um
what do you think that meant to
him uh that
this person who he
seemed to have the deepest respect for
and as a leader uh what do you think
that would have meant to him
i can't speculate on what he was
thinking or feeling but perhaps
something like a lot of us have been
feeling that when someone well known
dies and the queen
is
known around the world and was known
around the world when someone of that
stature dies i think we often all stop
and reflect about our own parents dying
or people that we love dying that it
makes us remember the transitoryness of
life and that people you love do
disappear from the scene and so who
knows but perhaps he was thinking of
that um his father died he's he's
suffered losses in his life and the
queen's death i think has been a moment
for reflection and and i you know as i
say i can't speak for him but i'm
wondering if that is part of it
certainly i know a lot of people i know
are saying that you it makes you think
again of those you've lost
professor mcmullen i think uh that's a
very very important and
uh significant thought to end on thank
you very much indeed for your time
thank you
princess elizabeth as she then was was
in kenya when she learned from her
husband the devastating news that her
father george vi had died and she had
become queen
she attended ascended to the throne on
the steps of the state house in nairobi
unusually following a proclamation in
the kenyan capital
that proclamation is similar to those
which have taken place across the
commonwealth today for her son charles
iii
alastair bunkel sent this report from
nairobi on the queen's kenya connection
kenya is where the reign of queen
elizabeth started but her death has
stirred mixed emotions for a country
that didn't always have the easiest
relationship with the late model
in 1952 the then princess elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
prince philip her trip was cut short
when her father king george vi
unexpectedly died the young princess
became queen whilst on kenyan land a
date that many still fondly remember in
nairobi's rail museum the queen's royal
visits are celebrated
so when she visited kenya in 1993 she
used the royal trade
on her way to nanuki
you've got er there elizabeth regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in kenya during that
time
and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history britain's
colonial rule the british crackdown on
the mao mao uprising killed an estimated
11 000 kenyans and many held the queen
as britain's head of state responsible
kenya was colonized by by the british
and being colonized by the british
people have lost their fathers they have
lost their grandparents here fighting
for independence fighting for
independence from the colonies
so again when this is a colonizer there
are people who that is the feeling they
have wow the association with the queen
has also had some positives yes yes
they're positives i mean the
colonization also brought positive
things but again there's the negativity
bit of the losses that kenya as a people
went through
signs of british colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
elizabeth highway when it opened but
since renamed freedom road after
independence
time has healed only so much here
king charles ascended to the throne
replacing the mother this in itself
marks a new beginning i don't think
a great fraction of kenyans will look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical
will still continue to pose their hard
and uncomfortable questions and will
demand
economic justice
political justice and reparations
britain and kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
commonwealth
but a new king
won't necessarily be a new beginning
alice to bundle sky news in nairobi
let's stay for a moment with that theme
the reaction to the queen's death in the
commonwealth
despite a growing republican movement in
australia her death has overwhelmingly
been met with public sorrow
skies skies cordelia lynch report from
sydney on australia's response
[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the queen once walked her son must
now follow and here in australia it is a
turning point
we just loved her we just loved it the
older we got
the more we could relate to her because
she felt like she was just always there
for us i'm just like a lot of other
older australians we're just grieving
because
she was the queen of australia a lot of
people that's lost on a lot of people it
felt like um the queen was almost um
immortal at some point you know she uh
she's lived a long time and
yeah i mean even
though she
was quite old when she passed it still
came as a shock
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit these shores
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population spellbound
i want to tell you all
how happy i am to be amongst you
and how much i look forward to my
journey through australia
such outbursts of spontaneous affection
she loves this country she loved this
country i should say
she'd been here 16 times and you don't
do that if you don't like the place and
she came back again and again and again
and she found the same thing again and
again again warmth affection
i think she really admired the
resilience of australians
who work and live off the land here it's
very nice to see you in person this time
yes your majesty
scott morrison admired her ability to
make light work of calming his nerves
she had he says a regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see her like again but
we won't
where do you see that relationship
with the crown going there does remain a
strong connection and an appreciation
i mean our success in australia
is in no small part
due to the stability of our democracy of
our constitutional system and the crown
sits at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic and that
conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that
feels strikingly rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen that appears enduring
cordille sky news sydney australia
with the passing of her majesty the
queen some sporting events were
cancelled today as a mark of respect
however some did go ahead with those
present taking the opportunity to pay
tribute to the late queen
our sports correspondent rob harris has
been looking at some of those sporting
with solemnity and silence
players and fans bonded by sport uniting
at the oval to mourn their monarch
[Music]
a rendition of god save the king the
first broadcaster a sporting event since
the accession of charles before the
delayed start of england's test against
south africa
cricket resuming while some other sports
remain suspended in britain
the powerful tributes here at the oval
showed why qriket leaders wanted their
sport to resume to honour they said the
life and service of the queen she wants
to use her christmas broadcast to talk
about the power of sporting being able
to bring people together
and we've seen here just how that can
take place
i personally wouldn't have wanted to
play i'd wanted two or three days just
to reflect and think about
all the wonderful things she's done i
can also understand the thinking about
people coming together with sport it's a
fine line and i suppose really at the
end of the day you do what you think is
best
football was the main sport choosing to
shut down
food destined for premier league
stadiums like liverpool donated to food
banks
a decision is yet to be taken on whether
domestic football is played next weekend
before the queen's funeral
in golf play at the pga championship at
wentworth was suspended following the
queen's death on thursday
it restarted on saturday after the
government left it at the discretion of
each sport whether to hold events
rugby union had split decisions across
the united kingdom with the games only
in england this weekend
horse racing the sporting passion of
queen elizabeth that once gave her
success in the gold cup at ascot resumes
with the saint ledger on sunday
at the cricket in london those no longer
able to play sport this weekend taking
the chance to pay respect
i was ignored i couldn't play football
but happy to come here
when kind of everyone just went silent
and that was unprompted it was uh yeah
it was quite special a bit emotional got
a little bit choked up after the mix i'm
a monarchist just having brought up and
i believe and um i thought it was really
moving actually yes in a nation grieving
sport bringing people together to
express condolences and gratitude to the
queen's service and reign rob harris sky
news the oval
our correspondent laura bundock is here
with me once again laura um
somebody rather unkindly
said today they know that there's
continuity because today there was an
england batting collapse but more
broadly um i think sporting fixtures uh
it showed that there's very deep feeling
in the country and i think we're seeing
that
in the turnout here in the winter aren't
we i think so and more i think is
striking being stood here outside
buckingham palace not just the silence
but the size of the crowd and the fact
that here we are at this time of night
and the the people are still coming
they're accused of people walking as i
say quietly peacefully many of them
carrying flowers and a lot of those
flowers are now being moved and the size
of that mound of flowers is quite
something it is huge and we saw in
windsor as well with that remarkable
impromptu walk about a walk about we did
not expect to see not just the prince
and princess of wales but of course at
their invitation uh harry and megan the
duke and duchess of sussex as well we
are seeing deep crowds there and i think
you notice as well the crowds ranging in
age
it's not perhaps the sort of crowd you
would expect
at a royal event i was here for the
jubilee and certainly i think
you would recognize the crowd there but
here i feel
it is a wider range of people and the
new king spoke of that in his speech
yesterday that very public his important
first address really to the nation
talking about his recognition of the
backgrounds and beliefs and the range of
that and i think that is reflected in
the people who are coming and of course
these crowds will grow particularly once
the queen's coffin arrives
back in london um for the lying in state
where
you are imagining thousands and
thousands and thousands will want to
turn up to file past i mean it's
interesting i mean what one thing that
seems
clear is that there's going to be going
on for nine or ten days and you would
expect
if you like the intensity to drop but
there's no sign of that at the moment
absolutely the opposite i think i was
struck
late last night walking through the
parks how many people were still here
and again tonight this crowd is moving
and it is moving in one direction
towards the palace and as i say in
windsor you saw on the long walk the
huge the deep crowds there and you can
only imagine that these crowds are going
to grow and grow crescendoing towards
monday week when of course the big state
funeral will take place and you'd expect
many people here will want to be as
close as they can or in the vicinity of
such an occasion well i suspect you and
i will be in this vicinity a lot over
the next week and a bit
laura thank you very much indeed
now over the course of her reign the
queen became perhaps the most
photographed person ever to have lived
and her image used in everything from
pop art to punk
katie spencer has been looking at the
life of a cultural icon
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous her
image at the core of british culture
the queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premiere of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she played in maintaining
the allure of brand britain
i remember when i was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
prince philip who was about the best
looking man
in the world i mean everybody at school
had a crush on him and i kept scrapbooks
of the queen everything that was in the
papers or the magazines i cut out and it
was
princess elizabeth's wedding
and she was a fairy tale princess she
really was she was gorgeous she had a
hand span waist big wonderful eyes we
all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her platinum jubilee
um
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the relentless public
infatuation with this woman
if you imagine i'm going to drop
everything and come down to london
before i attend to my grandchildren
who've just lost their mother celebrated
by our greatest artists from lucy and
freud to andy warhol her portraits now a
huge part of her legacy
i remember when i was first commissioned
it was a daunting prospect you know the
queen the most portrayed woman in
history i asked if man would like to
rest in between shots
that'd be fine just i was conscious of
all the light onto her so
she closed her eyes and
that was the moment it was you know
it didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at
sitting for artists was part of her
cultural duty but she also inspired some
significant unofficial art an
anti-establishment target epitomized on
the cover of the 1977 sex pistols single
a defaced lightness and easy act of
rebellion
if you went to most west indians home at
the time they would probably have a
picture of the queen on the wall as well
as a picture of jesus
while rock photographer dennis morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the queen's
silver jubilee he was following the
pistol's provocative boat trip on the
thames
at that time um the monarchy was very
very strong we were
not particularly liked for being
anti-monarchy in that sense as i grew
older and knew more and more about it i
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot
to hold something like that together in
the way she has over the years so you
know for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many british artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
arts for those who embraced her
magisterial authority or rebelled
against it she inspired her influence
over british culture irrefutable and
unique
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
katie spencer sky news
that's all for this special program
coming up next is news at 10 with
jillian joseph and all of today's
historic developments
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is sky news at 10
live from buckingham palace
the making of a monarch king charles is
confirmed as the nation's sovereign as
an ancient ceremony broadcast to the
public for the very first time
in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray for the guidance and help
of almighty god
watching on and confirming him as king
charles iii some of the most senior
figures in the country including every
living prime minister
united in grief the new prince of wales
pays tribute to his grandmother and
makes a surprise appearance in windsor
alongside princess catherine prince
harry and megan
very nice to meet you guys
thank you very much
a silent tribute some sports resume
although not football as buckingham
palace confirms queen elizabeth's state
funeral will be held on monday september
the 19th
and from pop art to punk how the queen
became a global cultural icon
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
good evening from buckingham palace it
used to be said that showing the inner
workings of the monarchy might destroy
the mystique well the new king is
already testing that belief
today started with live television
coverage of a ceremony dating back at
least 700 years that which has never
previously been seen by the outside
world
it ended with the king his queen consort
the prince and princess of wales and the
duke and duchess of sussex on royal
walkabouts pressing the flesh literally
embracing their people on the streets of
windsor and here outside buckingham
palace more on that in a moment first
our correspondent ran on mills reports
on the proclamation of the king
it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual that was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start
and now the end of the second
elizabethan age with one voice and
consent of tongue and heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord charles iii
for the first time cameras were allowed
inside as politicians past and present
of all political persuasions gathered
inside st james's palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy councillors
to acknowledge formally the change of
reign
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
and of his other realms and territories
king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith
god save the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by king charles
his heir and queen consort close by
as we were all able to witness a moment
never seen before
a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting
personally declaring his intention to
serve
my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you the entire nation
and i think i may say the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we have all
suffered
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks
for this most faithful life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
and in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me and to which i now dedicate what
remains to me
of my life
i pray
for the guidance and help
of almighty god
it's the personal touches
his family around him the inkwell on the
table given him as a gift by prince
william and prince harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives from the commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much
her majesty the queen had given us but
also
welcoming the new king
and for the new king charles to make
those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way i think was moving for
everyone
and it is a moment i'm sure no one in
that room will ever forget
[Music]
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
echoed in the city of london as the
second proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal exchange
god save the king
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the united kingdom
for now buckingham palace remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the mall
but behind them a king who wants to be
seen
who wants us to understand what we're
now witnessing as like us he's quickly
had to adjust
rhiannon mills sky news at st james's
palace
well the king's walkabout today followed
one outside windsor castle this
afternoon by the prince and princess of
wales together with the duke and duchess
of sussex they walked together to meet
crowds of well-wishers and thank them
for their support earlier prince william
had made his first public statement
since her death saying the queen had
been by my side at my happiest moments
and during the saddest days of my life
helen ann smith reports on the royal
princes united in grief
on a momentous week this was a momentous
statement
two brothers two couples showing the
world the queen's loss should pull
together not push apart
there was clearly a lot of emotion
reassurance between the sussexes this no
doubt nerve-wracking for them
and a distance still
and awkwardness perhaps
greeting people connecting is what these
four have always done best
there was welcome and warmth
grief and gratitude
and steadfast support for the second in
line
what did you think about getting the
selfie with
them even seeing him today i don't know
whether it's just me but you kind of
feel like you kind of know him in a way
yeah i think that people are still young
they kind of see everything
from a younger perspective
rather than charles up there
this was not the first gesture of public
unity this week
a clear desire to show that while rifts
may not be healed they are being worked
on
there's a huge amount of affection here
and across the country for those we used
to call the young royals and there's
been much said over the years about the
energy and sparkle they bring to the
monarchy but getting older as it does
has brought its difficulties
difficulties they now need to manage
amidst their grief and a significant
step up in responsibility
and that no doubt bears heavily on the
new prince of wales
he has new titles new duties and a new
daunting task to start preparing to be
the next monarch
in an emotional statement he said of the
queen she was by my side at my happiest
moments and she was by my side during
the saddest days of my life i knew this
day would come but it will be some time
before the reality of life without
granny will truly feel real he concluded
i will honor her memory by supporting my
father the king in every way i can
at belmoral 2 more of the queen's
children and grandchildren came out to
see how much the public adored her
a family loss in a family where she was
the anchor amidst its fair share of
storms
thank you so much
thank you everyone and that was clearly
the message here too
two brothers on different paths putting
that to one side to look back and
remember yes
but also to look forward
helen and smith sky news in windsor
well buckingham palace has now released
details of key moments in the coming
days culminating in the queen's funeral
on monday the 19th of september that
will be a bank holiday
but before then the queen's coffin will
be moved from balmoral tomorrow before
members of the public are given the
chance to pay their respects in person
our royal correspondent laura bundock
reports now
on the queen's funeral arrangements
your majesty
the king has spoken of heavy
responsibilities
and this is the inescapable reality a
diary of duties meetings with
dignitaries and like any bereaved son
the planning of a funeral
we now know on sunday the queen's coffin
will leave balmoral for the palace of
hollywood house in edinburgh
on monday the king and queen consort
will travel to westminster hall where
both houses of parliament will express
condolences and the king will make his
reply
the queen's coffin will be taken to
saint giles's cathedral in edinburgh the
king and queen consort and other members
of the family will follow the coffin in
a procession
and for 24 hours the coffin will rest in
the cathedral so the public can pay
their respects
that evening the king and other royals
will mount a vigil
on tuesday the king and queen consort
will visit northern ireland
meanwhile that evening the queen's
coffin arrives in london and will rest
at buckingham palace
the following day on wednesday the
coffin will be taken to the palace of
westminster in a silent procession
followed by the king and royal family
the queen's coffin will arrive here at
westminster hall for the lying in state
five days during which members of the
public can pay their respects in person
there will be echoes of the past this is
the lying in state of king george vi in
1952. back then huge queues formed to
file past the coffin
similar scenes are expected now
on friday the king and queen consort
visit wales as their tour of the nations
continues
and on monday the 19th of september the
state funeral a procession will take the
queen's coffin to westminster abbey
the service will start here at 11
o'clock there'll be a bank holiday to
mark the day and afterwards a committal
service at windsor as the late queen is
finally laid to rest
it will be beautifully put together
bringing together all the agencies of
the state and the armed forces with the
finest drill the best pageantry and the
noblest of ceremonial in westminster
abbey it will be
a great salute to a wonderful queen
history tells us there will be huge
crowds last seen at the funeral of the
queen mother
but perhaps none will match the moment
of the final farewell of her daughter
queen elizabeth ii
[Music]
and laura's with me now laura the day
started very formally didn't it with the
the proclamation but uh ended anything
but with the royals on walkabout what a
huge contrast and what a reflection i
think of the role uh itself we saw the
new king formally proclaimed in what was
a historic an ancient an arcane event
which i think to some extent felt a
little inaccessible and then of course
we had the exact opposite the moments on
the mall as the king was driven up the
mall got out of the car to meet people
we know that's something he really is
keen to do as he tours the nations in
the coming days and of course the
walkabouts in windsor it was expected we
would see the new prince and princess of
wales it was not expected that they
would have also invited the sussexes
megan and harry were there as well and
the queen i think the late queen always
spoke of her soft power this convening
power and perhaps we saw an echo of that
with the four of them making that walk
as they went to meet those deep crowds
now and i think as we're seeing here
tonight almost in silence the crowds are
growing even this time of night we're
seeing more and more people arriving and
i think that's the striking thing that
the people want to come and what we will
see obviously on wednesday with the
lying in state i think the crowds will
build and build and you can imagine the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people probably some of those here as
well who will want to pay their last
respects who will want to file past the
queen's coffin when it arrives at
westminster hall laura thank you
and the walkabouts here in windsor are
dominating tomorrow's front pages
including the mirror their headline
reunited for granny
and you can scroll through the front
pages while watching our press preview
by scanning the qr code on your screen
now
joining me from 10 30 this evening will
be journalist and author christina
patterson and former editor of ok
magazine and the sunday express martin
townsend
wrexham was due to be celebrating
becoming a city this weekend its new
status conferred as part of the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations instead
its residents are coming to terms with
the death of the monarch and the
beginning of a new era of royal rule
katarina vitozi has been looking at how
one community has been dealing with a
new royal reality
[Music]
today in wrexham as church bells rang
out to mark king charles's accession
inside a model of the late queen's crown
came down
there was meant to be a party here today
to mark wrexham getting city status
celebrations now obviously postponed
the late queen granted city status and
this was the day when we were going to
have the formal official celebration to
mark that so we had a really big service
involved so
at this point on saturday morning we
were expecting the place to be sort of
full of people and full of
bustle what's the mood been like over
the last few days
it's just been a sort of yeah almost a
sense of unreality that we can't quite
take it in because she's been such a
constant for the whole of our lives
really
wrexham has a royal pedigree
even if history hasn't always been kind
to the place itself
at wrexham they started a tour of a
thoroughly depressed area where the old
heavy industries have failed and a
desperate attempt is being made to
attract new companies specifically in
light industry
things have been changing pretty fast
here in wrexham the town becoming a city
it's football teamed and taken over by
hollywood actor ryan reynolds and now
wrexham and indeed the whole of wales
has got a new prince and princess
alison williams met princess diana here
in 1991 and now welcomes her son prince
william and his wife taking on the role
i think william and kate are amazing
i think they will make a brilliant
prince princess of wales it's nice that
they lived here for so long
it means that they're interested and
they understand
more about whales
the new prince and princess of wales
also bring with them this
[Music]
a way of operating online that's as
slick as in real life
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck tonight
but in a moment where the monarchy is
looking to its future for some even
these social media savvy younger royals
feel somewhat distant
on their instagram they post all these
pretty things this stuff and you know we
didn't get to see that it would be
impossible for them to feel relatable to
anyone in our generation at the very
least anyway because of the struggles
we're having with the inflation and like
living crisis you know they don't have
to deal with that as much as a slot
that's what we all want as a country we
want them to bring
the uk into the new generation and be
more relatable he's got a look back to
his grandfather and his father's
footsteps for instance she got the duke
of edinburgh award and then the prince's
trust award
in the moment the queen died royal roles
shifted
titles changed but the responsibility
remains to engage the public and
preserve a legacy
cashmere rivertotsi sky news in wrexham
as well as being queen of the united
kingdom elizabeth ii was of course queen
of the commonwealth that too will be the
role of her successor king charles iii
a long association with australia has
held at bay the republican movement
there and while her death has already
raised new questions amongst some there
the predominant emotion has been sorrow
cordelia lynch reports from sydney on
australia's response
[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the queen once walked her son must
now follow and here in australia it is a
turning point we just loved her we just
loved it the older we got
the more we could relate to her because
she felt like she was just always there
for us i'm just like a lot of other
older australians we're just grieving
because
she was the queen of australia a lot of
people that's lost on a lot of people it
felt like the queen was almost um
immortal at some point you know she uh
she's lived a long time and
yeah i mean even
though she
was quite old when she passed it still
came as a shock
she was the first reigning monik to
visit these shores
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population spellbound
i want to tell you all
how happy i am to be amongst you
and how much i look forward to my
journey through australia
such outbursts of spontaneous affection
she loves this country she loved this
country i should say
she'd been here 16 times and you don't
do that if you don't like the place and
she came back again and again and again
and she found the same thing again and
again warmth affection
i think she really admired the
resilience of australians
who work and live off the land here
it's very nice to see you in person this
time yes your majesty
scott morrison admired her ability to
make light work of calming his nerves
she had he says a regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see her like again but
we won't
where do you see that relationship
with the crown going there does remain a
strong connection and an appreciation
i mean our success in australia is in no
small part
due to the stability of our democracy of
our constitutional system and the crown
sits at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic
and that conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that
feels strikingly rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen that appears enduring
cordelia lynch sky news sydney australia
princess elizabeth as she then was was
in kenya when she learned from her
husband the devastating news that her
father george vi had died and she had
become queen
she ascended to the throne on the steps
of the state house in nairobi following
a proclamation in the kenyan capital
similar to those which have taken place
across the commonwealth today for her
son
aleister bunkel sent this report from
nairobi on the queen's kenya connection
kenya is where the reign of queen
elizabeth started but her death has
stirred mixed emotions for a country
that didn't always have the easiest
relationship with the late model
in 1952 the then princess elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
prince philip her trip was cut short
when her father king george vi
unexpectedly died
young princess became queen whilst on
kenyan land a date that many still
fondly remember in nairobi's rail museum
the queen's royal visits are celebrated
so when she visited kenya in 1993 she
used the royal trade
on her way to nanuki
you've got er there elizabeth regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in kenya during that
time
and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history britain's
colonial rule the british crackdown on
the mao mao uprising killed an estimated
11 000 kenyans and many held the queen
as britain's head of state responsible
kenya was colonized by by the british
and being colonized by the british
people have lost their fathers they have
lost their grandparents here fighting
for independence fighting for
independence from the colonies
so again when this is a colonizer there
are people who that is the feeling they
have wow the association with the queen
has also had some positives yes yes
they're positives i mean the
colonization also brought positive
things but again there's the negativity
bit of the losses that kenya as a people
went through
signs of british colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
elizabeth highway when it opened but
since renamed freedom road after
independence
time has healed only so much here
king charles ascended to the throne
replacing the mother this in itself
marks a new beginning i don't think
uh
a great fraction of kenyans will look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical
will still continue to pose their hard
and uncomfortable questions and will
demand
economic justice
political justice and reparations
britain and kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
commonwealth
but a new king
won't necessarily be a new beginning
alistair bundle sky news in nairobi
well the face of britain changed
immeasurably over the course of the late
queen's reign in no small part that was
down to the connection with the
commonwealth and the many people from
those countries who chose to make the uk
their home sky's lisa holland has been
speaking to members of the uk's
commonwealth communities
you'll call you grandma yes
in south london friends and family call
louise the queen of brixton
not just because she's a
great-great-grandmother who fostered
more than 20 children but at 96 years of
age she was born on exactly the same day
as queen elizabeth ii
they call you the queen of brixton i
hear yes yes yes when
i had birthday
comes up at that time i said it he's the
queen
birthday and from me too
i feel good
louise came to britain as part of the
windrush generation
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set but as she watched the
proclamation of a new king she recalled
the late queen visiting jamaica in the
1950s the wave talk
to everyone and we've revealed back
in multicultural brixton scratch the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the queen's decades of
global commonwealth tours
when i was at school when i remember the
helicopter land
at the back of the school i'm sierra
from that um no it's not the time for
morning
now it's the time to celebrate the lady
life she'll live our life to the max
she's always made everyone feel like
part of the commonwealth part of
britain you know so i just think that
the world's a poorer place without her
what's also clear is just how
significant the queen's global influence
and standing was in so many countries
around the world
there is no
queen anywhere else like only united
kingdom
in this fabric shop we met bill al who
said it was watching the queen from a
young age which inspired him to want to
move to the uk from india nearly 20
years ago we always heard about the news
like queen sometime picture coming on
the newspaper what's it like michael who
grew up in ghana says the queen's legacy
will live on
she's a very strong brand now we've got
a king she he might probably follow the
same footsteps that the mum left behind
britain's new king already has the good
will of those who revered his mother to
help build his own future as monarch
lisa holland sky news south london
now some sporting events including all
football from the premier league to
grassroots games were cancelled today as
a mark of respect for elizabeth ii
however some did go ahead with those
present taking the opportunity to pay
tribute to the queen our sports
correspondent rob harris reports on some
of those sporting tributes
we recognize our immense contribution to
the nation
across the commonwealth and around the
world
cricket returning with solemnity and
silence
players and fans bonded by sport uniting
at the oval to mourn their monarch
[Music]
a rendition of god save the king the
first broadcaster a sporting event since
the accession of charles before the
delayed start of england's test against
south africa
cricket resuming while some other sports
remain suspended in britain
the powerful tributes here at the oval
showed why qriket leaders wanted their
sport to resume to honor they said the
life and service of the queen she wants
to use her christmas broadcast to talk
about the power of sporting being able
to bring people together
and we've seen here just how that can
take place i personally wouldn't have
wanted to play i'd wanted two or three
days just to reflect uh and think about
um all the wonderful things she's done i
can also understand the thinking about
people coming together with sport it's a
fine line and i suppose really at the
end of the day you do what you think is
best
football was the main sport choosing to
shut down food destined for premier
league stadiums like liverpool donated
to food banks
a decision is yet to be taken on whether
domestic football is played next weekend
before the queen's funeral in golf play
at the pga championship at wentworth was
suspended following the queen's death on
thursday
it was started on saturday after the
government left it at the discretion of
each sport whether to hold events rugby
union had split decisions across the
united kingdom with the games only in
england this weekend
horse racing the sporting passion of
queen elizabeth that once gave her
success in the gold cup at ascot resumes
with the saint ledger on sunday
at the cricket in london those no longer
able to play sport this weekend taking
the chance to pay respect
i was ignored that i couldn't play
football but happy to come here to watch
the quicker when kind of everyone just
went silent and that was unprompted it
was uh yeah it was quite special a bit
emotional i got a little bit choked up
after the mix i'm a monarchist just
having brought up and i believe and um i
thought it was really moving actually
yes in a nation grieving sport bringing
people together to express condolences
and gratitude to the queen's service and
reign rob harris sky news the oval
[Applause]
some other news now and away from the uk
the war in ukraine has seen a major
development today with ukrainian forces
making gains in the east of the country
russia's defense ministry has said it's
pulling back troops from key areas after
a ukrainian counter-offensive
russia is said to have been taken by
surprise by ukraine's advances
ukraine launched its counter-offensive
in the east earlier this week
in a daily update uk defence officials
said ukraine's forces have made advances
in around 31 miles into previously
russian-held territory
the attack is said to have left
thousands of russian troops increasingly
isolated near the key city of israel the
offensive is now seeking to sever the
russian supply lines near kupjanz and
trap thousands of troops in israel
overnight president zielenski said
ukraine had retaken 30 settlements in
the harkeev region
our security and defense editor deborah
haynes has this report from eastern
ukraine
this is the gateway to a key city that
russian forces captured in the first
weeks of the war
but these are ukrainian troops
they're part of a lightning advance
retaking swathes of territory across the
kharkiv region
punching through russia's defenses
driving its troops back
in order to achieve the stated goals of
the special military operation to
liberate donbass a decision was made to
regroup the russian troops stationed in
baliklia and isian regions to build up
our efforts in the direction of donetsk
regrouping sounds more like retreating
to reinforce russia's positions in the
crucial donbass region
the southern russian order came as
ukrainian troops celebrated the
recapturing of the small city of
balaklia the national flag flying high
once more
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclava the first major city in our
offensive i'm sure that it will not be
our last
russia's worst nightmare appears to be
unfolding in eastern ukraine
it could be their gravest setback since
the failure to capture keeve back in
march these pictures were taken from the
city of kupiansk
recapturing this place would deal a
significant blow to russia as it's been
an important supply route to support
russian forces in donbass russia's
decision to pull back some forces from
eastern positions is extraordinary but
ukraine is also waging counter-attacks
from the south the simultaneous
operations backed by western weapons
mark the biggest ukrainian offensive of
the war and could be a key turning point
if the games are sustained
[Music]
for those who've spent months under
russian occupation the relief is all too
clear to see
they've waited a long time for this
debrahim sky news in eastern ukraine
the family of a man shot dead by armed
metropolitan police in south london on
monday have called for the officer
involved to be immediately suspended
chris cabot died after being shot
following a chase with police in south
london on monday night a metropolitan
police officer is now the subject of a
homicide investigation over the shooting
today family and friends gathered in
westminster to march in his memory as
sadia chowdhury
[Music]
but the details of what happened when a
police firearms officer shot and killed
chris carver aren't
the iopc has launched an investigation
the family's questions don't end there
so the first demand for the family is
that we want to know if the officer
involved has been suspended um secondly
we want body cam footage of the incident
released to the family and finally we
want to have a timeline of how long the
investigation will take
that's the free demands and that's the
three demands that everyone came out
here to support
twenty-four-year-old chris carber was
fatally shot on monday police say the
vehicle he was driving in was involved
in a firearms offense in the days before
his death
he died after a single gunshot
he was unarmed
today his family described the police's
actions as inherently racist
and a friend of the family said people
need to find stamina to get justice
everyone here today i just encourage
everyone
[Music]
and i know it's probably
it's a very difficult thing to say
it's not even nice because no one should
have the stamina
to get justice
the metropolitan police force said the
officer involved is currently not on
operational duties
but the family's local mp says that may
not be enough
all relationships have to start with
communication the police inadequately
communicate with the family or the all
the community about the instances that
only deepens this trust and now we find
that we're in a position where there's
going to be a criminal investigation
which implies that something went
seriously wrong
the iopc says its teams are reviewing a
large amount of evidence and that the
launch of a criminal investigation
doesn't mean charges will necessarily
follow sardia chaudhary sky news in
london
[Applause]
in response to claims made that they are
inherently racist the metropolitan
police said that it understands this
shooting is a matter of great concern
particularly for our black communities
let's return now to the late queen and
over the course of her reign she became
perhaps the most photographed person
ever to have lived with her image used
in everything from high art to pop art
and punk
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer has been looking at how
the queen became a cultural icon
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous her
image at the core of british culture
[Applause]
the queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million
it was the premiere of sorts for the
lifelong pivotal role she played in
maintaining the allure of brand britain
i remember when i was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
prince philip who was about the best
looking man in the world i mean
everybody at school had a crush on him
and i kept scrapbooks of the queen
everything that was in the papers or the
magazines i cut out and it was um
princess elizabeth's wedding and she was
a fairy tale princess she really was she
was gorgeous she had a hand span waist
big wonderful eyes we all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her platinum jubilee
um
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the relentless public
infatuation with this woman
if you imagine i'm going to drop
everything and come down to london
before i attend to my grandchildren
who've just lost their mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
lucy and freud to andy warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her legacy
i mean when i was first commissioned it
was a daunting prospect you know the
queen the most portrayed woman in
history i asked if man would like to
rest in between shots
that'd be fine just conscious of all the
light onto her so
she closed her eyes and
that was the moment it was you know
it didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at
sitting for artists was part of her
cultural duty but she also inspired some
significant unofficial art an
anti-establishment target epitomized on
the cover of the 1977 sex pistols single
a defaced lightness and easy act of
rebellion
if you went to most west indians home at
the time they would probably have a
picture of the queen on the wall as well
as a picture of jesus
while rock photographer dennis morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the queen's
silver jubilee he was following the
pistols provocative boat trip on the
thames
at that time
the monarchy was very very strong we
were
not particularly liked for being
anti-monarchy in that sense as i grew
older and knew more and more about it i
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot
to hold something like that together in
the way she has over the years so you
know for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many british artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honours for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
arts for those who embraced her
magisterial authority or rebelled
against it she inspired her influence
over british culture irrefutable and
unique
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
katie spencer sky news
you are now watching a special edition
of the press preview live from
buckingham palace a first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with journalist and author
christina patterson and former editor of
ok magazine and the sunday express
martin townsend
so let us see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the front of the observer pictures
our new king charles iii as he ascends
to the
throne reunited for granny reads the
front of the mirror as the duke and
duchess of cambridge and the duke and
duchess of sussex are pictured together
for the first time in mourning
the sunday times also leads with that
story with the headline warring
windsor's awkward troost honor the queen
the daily star also looks at the two
royal couple's reunion
reunited in sorrow reads the front of
the sunday telegraph
and this same story is also on the front
of the sun on sunday their headline all
for one
the sunday express follows this story
too with the headline together for
granny william hands olive branch to
harry
and peace for gran reads the front of
the sunday people
and we are joined tonight by journalist
and author christina patterson and
former editor of okay magazine and the
sunday express martin townsend welcome
to you both let's start with the
observer um should we having a look at
uh that front page pictured there king
charles iii
as he comes to the throne starting the
morning with the formalities of that
proclamation
christina
well i mean i think we're all reeling
actually it's all it all seems to be
happening so quickly that literally on
thursday afternoon the queen was our
monarch and now we have a new king and
the processes of state and constitution
have kicked in and he gave that
incredibly moving speech yesterday i i
would challenge anyone to watch that and
not have had a tear while they watched
it and today it was the kind of almost
bureaucratic side of things although
that was also pretty ceremonial with
ex-prime ministers and uh and so on so
things are kicking in quite quickly
really and i think we're all adjusting
to the fact that charles is now our king
but i must say he hasn't put a foot
wrong
since this happened and i i think you
know not everybody has loved him forever
but i think everyone is feeling an
enormous amount of sympathy and support
for him at the moment and i certainly
feel
when he gave that speech yesterday i i
couldn't help thinking i'd be quite
critical of him in the past but i
couldn't help thinking we're in good
hands
martin do you echo that what did you
make very much so yeah actually funnier
enough i bumped into our postman this
morning and he said to me i've never
really thought much about charles never
really cared for him very much but i saw
his speech yesterday and i thought he
was absolutely magnificent and i think
that's the point i think he started so
brilliantly yesterday and and today as
well
um this mixture of solemnity
and dignity but also the human touch all
the time you know talking about
you know his mother and you know love
for his mother and all of that and how
he was sharing in the in the nation's
grief so i just think it's been a
wonderful combination of of the solomon
and the hum and the human
and then today um really wanting to to
actually
get in touch with the people literally
physically yes out on the uh the streets
the walk about um
we saw people really wanting to to hear
from him and be close to him and then
you're almost tearing up
that was also incredibly moving the way
that he people wanted to kiss him and
shake his hand and he wanted i'm sure
there would have been i mean of course
he has security guards with him but
nobody can guarantee
absolute security at a time like this
but you know he is kind of fearless and
very much wanting to show that he's one
you know of the people as well as uh
sovereign but also as martin said i
think the emotional tone is very
interesting i think he is the queen as
we know was
known for stoicism and after the death
of princess diana she had to she felt
she was doing the right thing in
supporting her grandsons but you know
there was national anger at her lack of
emotion and she was kind of forced into
a kind of
u-turn in a way she had to give this
public speech sort of saying how sad she
was about the death of diana and i think
prince charles king charles there we are
already king charles is wanting to
already establish that times have
changed and as a nation we are more in
tune with our emotions now and also
there are issues he knows that um the
prince of wales as i must now call him
william you know that he is very keen on
talking about mental health issues and
so on and i think it is part of a subtle
shift in that direction
let's move on to the express and they're
reporting on the the queen's wish coming
true for charles what what exactly are
they referring to well they're referring
to the fact that he's he's become now
the head of the commonwealth which he's
always wanted to be
and you know it's been his dream
apparently since he was a small child
and he visited malta so
you know it's a wonderful moment for him
i mean it's obviously a big challenge
and um but he seems determined very
passionate about sort of doing his best
in that area so
um yeah that's his wish come true do you
think christina that we're going to to
see his role though as head of the
commonwealth change because of various
comments that he's made in rwanda in the
evolving commonwealth if it even remains
i mean how can it not change how can it
not change it it already feels somewhat
anachronistic but
but i know there is
there is still a lot of loyalty in in
you know a lot of the commonwealth for
the monarchy and um and i think we'll
just have to see but certainly the
political climate has changed and that
will be a huge challenge and
unfortunately for charles and i'm sure
he's intensely painfully aware of this
he does has so far not inspired and does
not generally inspire the kind of
adoration that the queen
has done and i think the queen was able
to
override
so much of the the politics of things
simply through the sheer force of her
personality i mean even i remember there
was footage of her first dance but i
can't remember whether it was the uh
king of ghana
who was it the guy
i think it was sorry the first dance
with the president was was it present
calendar and and that was like you know
the first time a white queen has danced
with a black man in public and that was
a huge thing at the time and i think you
know she
she was um
she was so widely loved and and that she
was kind of and of course things were
very very different then i think that
will be a challenge for charles and
we'll see i i i think he has learned so
much in his years of being sort of
probably too open about his political
views that i think he probably brings a
lot of wisdom to the role now
let's move on to the
telegraph i think we can bring up
next uh reunited in sorrow the
brothers and their
wives together again in that grief we
read that
uh the prince of wales got that one
correct um has actually extended the
olive branch
yes which i think has taken everyone
slightly by surprise today um
i was certainly surprised that they
appeared to have shared the same car to
uh to the to the uh the great walk i i
cannot imagine the atmosphere in that
car actually to some extent because i
think
it the the body language between them
did not seem particularly comfortable on
the walkabout
um and one wonders i mean
apparently it was it was william's idea
but i think it probably came from
charles initially and and i think
charles kind of planted the seed of it
yesterday in his speech when he
mentioned about megan and harry making a
life broad and all of that
um but it was a it was a it was a it was
something that i think a lot of the
crowd wanted to see
but it i think for them it felt like a
very kind of awkward moment
um
but let's face it this has to be
resolved and i think um efforts are
being made by william and by charles to
try and sort of resolve this situation
because i think the last thing that
charles needs in the early
months of his reign or years of his
reign is this sort of festering problem
in the pa you know it's sort of carrying
on um so i think he he and william are
both determined in their own ways
perhaps in william's case through gritty
teeth to to actually sort of make this
happen and have this kind of
um
you know bring this thing together and
and make peace as it were christina do
you get the sense that this is the end
of any feud if there was one no i don't
get that sense that it's the end of the
food but i feud but i think it will i
think that william has made a huge
effort and of course harry also i'm not
exactly sure what the power balance is
so whether harry would have to do what
his brother suggested i imagine not but
i think the thing is that um harry's
memoir is still looming and there is
enormous fear uh from
in the royal family about that and we we
read today that
um harry was told that megan would not
be welcome at the queen's deathbed um
presumably because of
things like her oprah interview and
spotify podcast recordings and so on i
think the trouble is that their business
model for surviving post-monarchy is
predicated on them um essentially
moaning about the royal family and their
experience the royal family and this
would be a very very bad time to be
doing that so i don't know what will
happen on that front i don't know
whether the publication of the memoir
will be delayed
and i think it will be very hard to see
that there will be real and genuine
reconciliation between particularly
charles well actually all of them
charles william and harry if their
memoir is truly explosive and critical
of them but we'll have to see on that
front yeah i think the memoir is a
really interesting point and it feels as
if
with the mood at the moment in the
country i think it would feel as if it
would make sense for him to delay that
because i just can imagine the
publication of it is going to be an
incredibly unpopular move given the
great wave of support for charles in the
in the country and obviously that all
the grief around the queen and
everything else i think the idea of
bringing that book out in was it
november i think it's quite it's sort of
quite imminent isn't it so
yeah and i mean i think also from the
publishers point of view do they really
want to be involved in that at this
stage yes sir remains to be seen whether
that will be delayed but what did you
make of the optics of the announcement
of the queen's death being made before
harry was able to get to balmoral
i just think it was yeah it was it was
unfortunate wasn't it but
i mean
it was just the way it it was i mean you
know i i think uh
i don't think it was anything deliberate
there i mean you know it was it was just
the sort of timing were sort of off
really um it didn't look good that's for
sure um but
i think you know at times like that and
there was quite a bit of confusion
really i mean it was smoother in some
ways but it was there was also slight
confusion people rushing up trying to be
there and obviously we know that not
everybody was there
but that's the way these things sort of
unfold so
on to the
sun let's take a look at that of
the royals looking at
flowers um that's also on the walkabout
that they they they went on there was
also the the other walk about with other
members in balmoral um where you could
see that that the family
was showing
much emotion and you know quite open
about their degree yeah well i think i
think the thing is that um it's not just
that you know the nation has lost a
queen she was absolutely adored by her
own family and i think she was
you know we saw generally uh in the
relatively emotionless side of her but i
think she was extremely funny i did have
the pleasure of meeting her twice and
and um i was actually just telling
trevor phillips um that uh
uh
the poet john agard um who later got the
queen's gold medal of poetry i was at a
party in buckingham palace in 2002
because i was helping to organize i was
running the poet society helping to
organize a golden jubilee poetry
competition and uh the poet john agard
was there and the queen came up and
talked to andrew motion then poet
laureate and me and john agard and he
was flirting with her and she was
laughing and she was just great fun and
you think gosh people don't really see
you like this and i think she was you
know she was she was funny she was witty
she was sharp obviously i barely knew
her but i mean i didn't know her i just
met her but people who who knew her well
um loved her and she was very kind so
they are all and i think you know harry
and william were very close to their
grandmother and she will be deeply
deeply missed by her family and it's
difficult for them because they have to
they go through this private grief at a
time of great public grief and they have
to kind of balance that and that's quite
difficult yes and very difficult for uh
king charles
taking on this mantle when
trying to to deal with with this grief
he's lost his his mother she was the
queen yeah she was his mother you know
you lose your mum i mean it's just you
know it's absolutely devastating i think
um and yes she's having to go through
that as well i mean the interesting
thing i think in terms of the love that
the the the the children had the
grandchildren having
for the queen came across when william
was talking about the fact that he had
this this amount of time with the queen
you know he was grateful for that amount
of time and then mentioned that kate had
had this amount of time and it was
almost like you know it was precious i
mean obviously she's been old
she's been old for a while and you know
the kind of shadow of what happened on
thursday has been there for a while and
i think that all of those years for
those precious years and i think the
fact that william immediately sort of
reflected on that just showed how valued
those were and how close they were they
are an incredibly close family
we're just going to move away from uh
the story today here and move to um
ukraine to finish off with uh sunday
times and uh the observer covering this
story and this is the
the pushback uh from ukraine it seems as
if fortunes are are turning
well
at the moment but it's been i think
they've taken the most territory they
since march which is absolutely
wonderful news and they've taken i think
cupiensk and isiam up in the northeast
and kubiansk is particularly important
because it's a supply uh
route for um russian soldiers in the
in the uh to the east so
it looks great i mean i think we hardly
dare breathe when it comes to ukraine
because putin will do absolutely
anything and he is prepared to
feed every
russian male in the country through the
meat grinder of his horrible horrible
operation but certainly it sounds as
though they've taken nearly a thousand
square miles of territory which is
phenomenal so long may it last and let's
hope they do succeed in taking back here
son and and kharkiv and um and you know
that this is the beginning of the end
but i have to say i i think there's a
long way to go on it
christina martin thank you very much for
the moment we have that run out of time
see you in the next hour for more do
stay with us on sky news as we reflect
on a remarkable day full of
extraordinary images
[Music]
this is sky news at 11 o'clock live from
buckingham palace the headlines this
evening
the making of a monarch king charles is
confirmed as the nation sovereign at an
ancient ceremony broadcast to the public
for the very first time
in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life i pray
for the guidance and help
of almighty god
watching on and confirming him as king
charles iii some of the most senior
figures in the country including every
living prime minister
united in grief the new prince of wales
pays tribute to his grandmother and
makes a surprise appearance in windsor
alongside princess catherine prince
harry and megan
very nice to meet you guys
thank you very much
a silent tribute some sports resume
although not football as buckingham
palace confirms queen elizabeth state
funeral will be held on monday september
the 19th
and from pop art to punk how the queen
became a global cultural icon
[Music]
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
good evening from buckingham palace it
used to be said that showing the inner
workings of the monarchy might destroy
the mystique while the new king is
already testing that belief today
started with live television coverage of
a ceremony dating back at least 700
years but which has never previously
been seen by the outside world it ended
with the king his queen consort the
prince and princess of wales and the
duke and duchess of sussex on royal
walkabouts pressing the flesh literally
embracing their people on the streets of
windsor and here outside buckingham
palace more on that in a moment first
our royal correspondent ran on mills
reports on the proclamation of the king
it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual that was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start
and now the end of the second
elizabethan age
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
for the first time cameras were allowed
inside as politicians past and present
of all political persuasions gathered
inside st james's palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy councillors
to acknowledge formally the change of
rain
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
and of his other realms and territories
king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith
god save the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by king charles
his air and queen consort close by
as we were all able to witness a moment
never seen before
a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting
personally declaring his intention to
serve
my laws ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you
the entire nation
and i think i may say the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we've all
suffered
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks
for this most faithful life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
and in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray
for the guidance and help
of almighty god
it's the personal touches his family
around him the inkwell on the table
given him as a gift by prince william
and prince harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives from the commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much
her majesty the queen had given us but
also
welcoming the new king
and for the new king charles to make
those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way i think was moving for
everyone
and it is a moment i'm sure no one in
that room will ever forget
[Music]
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
echoed in the city of london as the
second proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal exchange
god save the king
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the united kingdom
for now buckingham palace remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the mall
but behind them a king who wants to be
seen
who wants us to understand what we're
now witnessing as like us he's quickly
had to adjust
rihanna mills sky news at st james's
palace
the king's walkabout followed one
outside windsor castle this afternoon by
the prince and princess of wales
together with the duke and duchess of
sussex they walked together to meet
crowds of well-wishers and thank them
for their support earlier prince william
had made his first public statement
since her death saying the queen had
been by my side at my happiest moments
and during the saddest days of my life
helen smith reports on the royal princes
united in grief
on a momentous week this was a momentous
statement
two brothers two couples showing the
world the queen's loss should pull
together not push apart
there was clearly a lot of emotion
reassurance between the sussexes this no
doubt nerve-wracking for them
and a distance still
an awkwardness perhaps
greeting people connecting is what these
four have always done best
grief and gratitude
and steadfast support for the second in
line you've got a selfie with the new
prince of wales and the prince house how
did that make you feel
i'm happy i really liked it even seeing
him today i don't know whether it's just
me but you kind of feel like you kind of
know him in a way yeah i think that
people are still young they kind of see
everything from a younger perspective
rather than charles up there
this was not the first gesture of public
unity this week
a clear desire to show that while rifts
may not be healed they are being worked
on i think it was important to have that
unity at the moment so despite whatever
is going on outside of that so it's nice
nice to see i like to see them mending
the bridges and that sort of thing but
who knows it's been very hurtful for the
queen for their family so yeah if they
can put that to rest and start refresh
that probably the best for everybody
there's a huge amount of affection here
and across the country for those we used
to call the young royals and there's
been much said over the years about the
energy and sparkle they bring to the
monarchy but getting older as it does
has bought its difficulties difficulties
they now need to manage amidst their
grief and a significant step up in
responsibility
and that no doubt bears heavily on the
new prince of wales
he has new titles new duties and a new
daunting task to